alex jones is suing the january six
committee he is refusing to cooperate
and
good for him a bunch of other people
have as well and i think that these are
truly the worst of the worst it looks
like i think it's fair to say i think
most reasonable people would assume this
the goal of the committee is just to
stop a trump 2024 run we've got this
ongoing grand jury in new york is
actually a grand jury convened to indict
donald trump and grand juries tend to
indict so donald trump may very well get
indicted but at the very least at least
alex jones you'd expect him to and i'm
glad he is he's standing up he's
fighting back he's refusing and he
released a statement a while ago where
he said basically that they're going to
rope him in they're going to bring him
in they're going to ask him questions
they're going to claim he lied so he's
best just pleading the 5th and fighting
this so again good for alex we've also
got joe biden's administration basically
saying there's going to be death and
pain
for people just before christmas thanks
for that because they're unvaccinated
and we're going to get i believe
tomorrow big announcement about their
new measures and their plan for tackling
covet a lot of people think it's going
to be serious restrictions possibly
having to do with air travel especially
during the holidays this will be big and
we got a couple other crazy stories too
in that capacity we've got cory booker
we got elizabeth warren we got jim
cramer all triple vexed and boosted we
all got kovit so there's a theory i got
a theory
they lied about it they lied about
getting vaccinated how much you want to
bet these these people lied about it but
we'll talk about all that stuff and we
got a couple other stories that are
freaky we got three retired generals
saying that they believe there there is
a possibility of a military coup in 2024
because the military is straight divided
right now and something must be done
about it and then we've got an adviser
to the cia who tracks civil wars in
other countries saying that we are we
may be in the third phase already she
basically said there's three phases one
and two we've long since passed the
third phase we may have entered on
january 6. so of course january 6 is
like this this nightmare scenario for
these people but we'll get into all of
that joining us today to talk about this
and more it's fresh and fit hey you want
to introduce yourselves we're back man
we're on gains better now
hey man so uh that's fit
i'm fresh all right don't get confused
but uh yeah we're back man
happy to be here other than you guys
cool
what do you guys want to just uh explain
real quick what you guys do oh yeah we
should probably do that right they're
like why are these guys
random dudes there's some guy in a chain
and a guy in a skull shirt who the hell
are these guys no um myron gaines man we
have the fresh fit podcast we talk about
you know becoming a better man with the
number one men's podcast in the world we
talk about you know making money getting
girls getting in shape just becoming the
best version of yourself investing as
well yeah and investing exactly in fresh
sports into real estate investing and
cryptocurrency and all that stuff you
know i'm really big into real estate
about a close on my seventh property for
the year wow at the end of the month so
you know we're just all about helping
guys you know self-improve and
understand that the dating marketplace
has changed and you got a debt baby
that's a lot to manage seven properties
dude it's it is a lot but my pops helps
me out because i got a property in
florida and then connecticut and my dad
manages the connecticut products
are are you the founder of blm with how
many houses you have i am the founder i
am the founder actually
houses at like half a million bucks yeah
and she was like it's okay it's for my
family it's like oh you're you're a huge
family really well i don't i don't you
know i guess the issue is like i don't
know why i don't care you know like oh
famous person is rich like who knows
yeah i think if you're famous you're not
rich you're stupid well one of the other
things we'll get into as well is i guess
uh you you've been exposed as a fed
you're a fed yes i got doxxed
and i'm here he's the ops man yeah i'm
brother get out of here yeah man so you
know i got docs like you know that if
you google my real name which i won't
even say but at this point it is what it
is like you know basically like people
put out my real name and then if you
google my real name like an affidavit
comes back for a case i did right before
i resigned and you know i guess i'll
just say it at this point i was a former
special agent online investigations hsi
i did criminal investigations for from
2013 i was an agent in 2013 to 2020. i
was interning from 2010 to 2013. uh and
then i became an agent 2013 went to the
academy and then i you know got
stationed to loredo texas my first duty
station then i went to miami florida
fantastic career it was a great job you
know i have nothing bad to say about the
agency or uh the job itself during your
podcast right i'm sorry that was during
your podcast right yes i so i i was
doing the podcast uh and then you know
they didn't like my pod you know we talk
about controversial things like
womanizing so
so they didn't really like it and
they're like hey you know you got to
pick one you know because i had my my
business i was doing i was running my
fitness business on my podcast right and
then i also was doing my job uh with
with the feds and they're like hey like
you know you got to be testifying you
have to have a certain type of character
blah blah blah you know which i i
understood i get it you know i'm voiced
my opinion on youtube and it might not
be the best you know for testifying for
cases and i had a pretty big case at the
time so i got it but you know i was kind
of put in a weird position where i had
to make a choice so at the time we were
just expanding we had invested in the
studio so i said you know what i'm gonna
take a bet on myself and you know ended
up working out but you know i have again
nothing bad to say about the agency it
was a lot of fun we'll get into it yeah
i got some questions but we're going to
get into that sure a lot later of course
but hey guys it's pretty crazy out there
as you guys are hearing all the news
don't forget you have to obey dr fauci
and lord savior bill gates every day
don't forget to take your shots excuse
me shots how many that's medical advice
luke and i'm not giving any medical
advice yeah tell people to go talk to
their doctor medical doctors do whatever
you ought to do but just obey fouchy
bill gates at all costs i guess their
doctors are
they're they're beyond that they're
they're if they're super super doctors
like super god overlords so how many you
know shots exactly i think 1984 should
be fitting i think that exact number of
shots i think will definitely help slow
the spread and that's why i made this
t-shirt that reads 1984 shots to slow
the spread which you can exclusively get
on
thebestpoliticos.com and because you do
i'm here thanks so much for having me
i'm excited about this conversation
thanks so much for coming on no thank
you as well do you believe in
depopulation absolutely 100 percent i
think it's not that i don't believe it's
not that i believe in it a lot of very
powerful people do and that's what i
think of it what you'll get is in the
establishment they use the most extreme
version of what that means versus bill
gates literally doing a ted talk where
he's like we want to slow population
growth down you know what i mean so like
if you say that you could be referring
to bill gates you know doing research on
implantable birth control chips which is
a real thing but it sounds crazy i
didn't believe luke when he brought it
up yeah it's like bloomberg reporter
it's not even a big deal apparently to
these guys and if you mention that they
make it seem like you're talking about
some wild crazy conspiracies and all
stuff we'll get into it though before we
get started we got a great sponsor my
friends go to
backupsolarbank.com and you can get your
backup solar bank it's literally what it
is it's a 20 000 milliamp
solar-powered
charger there you go i think everybody
should have a backup battery so i always
have one i like to use these this one
can charge in the sun i think it charges
about 600 milliamps per day of with
sunlight so it can actually take a bit
but if you're in the middle of nowhere
if you're camping you're living rv life
or van life or something or you're just
going to be on a long trip it's good to
have this thing it's also got a
flashlight on it
go to backup solarbank.com you'll get 53
off and if you use the promo code
timcast20 you'll get an additional 20
off so this is pretty cool it's got
multiple charging ports and i gotta be
honest it's really that simple backup
solarbank.com check it out and uh thanks
for sponsoring the show guys and don't
forget go to invertedworldbook.com
because tim cast has officially released
its first book and uh here's what i find
something really funny first of all
with you guys supporting us we announced
this uh last week i think this was
friday wasn't it
we announced it's uh inverted world
tales from the inverted world book is
number one in like five different
categories already in new releases it's
already a bestseller which is absolutely
crazy and here's the best part this is a
book about ghosts ufos you know birds
missings the rat experiments simulation
theory and it ends with this big story
about a serial killer who's never been
found and been going on for like a
decade plus in long island and when you
go to amazon it says
people also customers also bought this
book and it's peter navarro's book and
it's michael malus book so you got the
anarchist handbook and you got in trump
time and then you've got tales in the
inverted world these books probably
shouldn't go together but because you
guys who watch support these books you
can clearly see it so uh tremendously
grateful to everybody who buys it and if
you're interested in this go to
invertedworldbook.com don't forget go to
timcast.com become a member if you want
to support our work we're gonna have a
members only segment coming up after the
show around 11 or so p.m and you can
like this video subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
let's just talk about mr alex jones
already we got cnn
reporting i love to use cnn for this
stuff alex jones sues house january 6
committee they say conspiracy theorist
and right-wing provocateur alex jones
says he will not comply with demands the
house select committee investigating
january 6 has made for his testimony in
records according to a new lawsuit he
filed on monday the lawsuit seeks to
block the subpoenas and claims jones
should be protected under the first
amendment he says that he will also
decline to answer questions so as not to
incriminate himself it lands in a moment
when the committee has pushed
aggressively for witnesses to share what
they know about the planning of the
january 6 rallies and they are
intentionally in my opinion that's what
i believe the january 6 committees are
intentionally conflating
the rallies with the people storming the
capital because there were a ton of
people who were just like regular people
they're waving american flags as trump
was like we're gonna go watch peacefully
and blah blah blah and then they went
home and there was a lady she was like a
psyops officer whatever in the army she
had nothing to do with anything at the
capitol she went to the rally gone
discharged there were a bunch of people
who have lost their jobs now apparently
the guy from bob's burgers has been
fired one of the guys because they're
like
we think he was there so this is look i
think the january 6 committee is
completely insane i think it's all bunk
bs and i think they're trying to strip
resources away from people who support
trump so that they can't support him as
well moving into 2024. well they have to
include the rallies because there's only
so many chewbacca guys grannies and feds
that they have to go after
that were a part of everything else that
happened that other day but it's also
interesting to note here that jones
actually volunteered to submit documents
and answers in writing for this
particular committee and then the
committee refused to do this they are
also requesting his phone records and as
we know the previous committee members
released private phone records there's
also some accusations about phone
records being doctored after they
garnered them from this january 6
committee so there's a lot of reasons
why a lot of people are saying i'm not
going to be complying with this and this
counter lawsuit is going to be
interesting because is i bet there's
probably going to be discovery on both
sides right
maybe i mean steve bannon tried that you
know he was filing saying he wanted
evidence released on what the government
had on this stuff and then the judge was
like no a lot of work for a misdemeanor
a lot of work for misdemeanors because i
think a lot of people forget that like
these charges that they're coming after
them for you know because i've read a
couple of the criminal complaints
written by the fbi agents and uh yeah
they're misdemeanor charges and it's a
lot of work you're going after a
misdemeanor charge and just so people
know like you know the feds typically
don't do a case unless it's number one a
felony and then number two it's going to
do substantial substantial time because
the thing is with the federal court
system is you have ausas right assist
united states attorneys and
i'm not selling a jerk but they're kind
of divas they don't take every case that
comes
they want they want to be able to they
want to win there's a reason why federal
prosecutors have such a high win rate
and the reason why is because they pick
and choose which cases they want to take
if the case isn't good enough they'll
say give it to the state or whatever
else
so for them to take misdemeanors and
push it to this level
is a fairly unorthodox obviously i get
it like you know hey these guys broke
into the capital it's a great act
you've dealt with this stuff yeah when
you were working at the uh was it
homeland hsi yeah well well so with this
type of stuff no not in particular i
investigated more like massive cartels
and everything but i'm very aware you
know what i mean right it was in your
periphery maybe yeah i mean
when you when you do you know criminal
investigations regardless of the agency
that you work for whether it's you know
the ea fbi whatever it is we all go
through the same federal court system we
use the same prosecutors same judges etc
and you get very familiar with what
every agency does as far as like you
know what they're
authority is and in a lot of cases you
have a lot of overlap you know like for
example atf dea fbi hsi we all have
something called title 21 which is we
can all do drug investigations to
certain extents but you know this is
where the fighting comes in between
agencies because hey well this is my
target no it's not well i'm title twenty
one designated well i am two blah blah
so you know so you get to be very
familiar with other agencies authorities
because of that very situation where
there can be confliction issues i have a
question there's a lot of circumstantial
evidence that there was a lot of
undercover federal agents involved in
january 6th whether provocateurs or
organizers do you think a lot of those
rumors are true and have you been able
to see some of the circumstantial
evidence suggesting that
i mean i wouldn't be surprised you know
um you know
because undercover so like the public
will think like it's undercover but it's
nothing more than an agent and plain
clothes because you know there is no
uniform for 1811's or special agents
like they wear regular clothing it's you
know sometimes they might wear a suit
like you see in the movie sometimes they
wear jeans sometimes they wear street
wear so it wouldn't be improbable for
one to be there you know just because of
the situation for them to be out there
and see what's going on and bam you got
your eye witnesses right there so you
know if you're like in a real undercover
capacity where you're like dealing with
criminals and everything else like that
and you're actually in an undercover
position then that's different yeah
there's some crazy videos out there of
guys clearly antagonizing clearly saying
we're gonna go to the capitol and then
those individuals weren't charged people
calling for violence not being charged
so there's a lot of questions
surrounding how involved the federal
government was and what extent did they
help organize and execute a lot of this
i could see that as potentially
problematic though from a prosecutor a
prosecutorial standpoint because like if
you if you had a
uc agent running around like
antagonizing the crowd like yeah let's
storm the capital blah blah like that
would create so many issues for the
prosecution to build a strong case
because you know then you can say well
they were they predisposed were they
going to do it did the government
actually take an active role in
entrapping them so like i could see how
that could be problematic you know
from a prosecution standpoint those
videos seem a bit over over the top uh
for me there's there's one guy and he's
like wearing like a red hoodie and he's
like everybody here's what we're gonna
do and i think i i agree with you on
this one
they're gonna they're gonna be able to
file that like the the defense is gonna
be able to get the evidence the
prosecution has exactly now it's
possible through discovery right right
they're gonna get everything like the
thing is is that anytime there's a
criminal case built like the the
prosecutor has to hand everything over
to the defense which is considered
discovery and there's actually huge
issues if they don't turn everything
over like they can get the spar they can
get hit with you know a bunch of issues
so they always turn everything over even
if it's not in their best interest to do
so so if they were to actually do a case
and then they found out the agents were
doing this stuff undercover and if they
antagonize the crowd i doubt any
prosecutor that wants to win would take
that case they'd be like hell no because
they used are very picky yeah yeah i
think it's entirely possible that these
guys were some kind of agent
provocateurs or whatever and we've seen
this at many protests even even
left-wing protests you'll see guys show
up it's very obvious that they start
violence and you don't know who they're
with the problem is
is it possible yes
i would say how do you prove it anyway
even if it was the case because it's not
going to be through any conventional
means if it's true so i think the simple
answer is probably just rowdy guys who
are like trying to cause trouble but
those guys weren't charged then there's
clear evidence who they are uh what they
did and and there's videos of them
inciting it and there's videos and calls
but why aren't they charged as the big
question and some people say that it's
it's evidence but it's not no it's not
it's actually really simple
they go to these guys because they know
who they are because they were vocal and
loud and they say you're going to go to
prison unless you tell us the names of
all the people who are with you and then
that guy says you got it boss and then
all of a sudden he's no longer in the
charging documents all of a sudden he's
no longer in criminal complaints because
he's cooperating and giving everybody up
so that's what i found really
interesting is that people immediately
assume a lot all the time especially
with the feds happens they find the one
guy look look you got all these videos
and the fads are trying to figure out
who these guys are do you know this
person do you know this person then you
get a video of a guy who's standing
there in plain view of the camera
yelling over and over again what to do
and they're like okay this is gonna be
an easy guy to find he's tall he's this
age he looks like this we know what he
sounds like he knows where he is they
find him and then they say who was with
you
who was talking with you give us your
phone and he says yes and then they say
okay we're not going to charge you
because you're cooperating that's giving
the government the benefit of the doubt
which i wouldn't give them
um
we're going to wait until this data and
information
in the court proceedings but for right
now there is a lot of circumstantial
evidence we'll see how it unfolds but
there's still so much that we don't know
even the video footage is being kept
away from the general public which is
crazy which is absolutely not for sure
it's because misdemeanors it's because
you watch a lot of this footage and it's
people bumbling around confused half the
time you know there was violence and
there was rioting but yeah it's it
i i definitely see both perspectives i'm
just giving you guys like
that perspective where like if you were
to actually do that as a uc it could be
extremely problematic to prosecution and
knowing prosecutors and how they operate
federal prosecutors especially they're
extremely selective on what they take
and yes i mean a lot of cases are built
on the backs of you know people
testifying against each other that's how
the big cases are made like if i was an
investigator and i got a guy and i see
him rallying everybody up well i know
for a fact this guy has some kind of
influence on these guys i'm gonna turn
him here's the important thing
alex jones is on video
multiple videos saying do not do this do
not be violent he's telling everyone not
to go to the capitol they're trying to
trick you he's trying to stop them of
all the people many people who were
there antagonizing alex jones was doing
the opposite the reason why i think
they're going after him they're going
after people who used to work for the
trump administration they're going after
jones
they want to drain as much of their
resources as possible so here's the
thing people need to understand about
getting called to to testify before this
committee
they're going to say we you know we
hereby subpoena you to release all phone
records all this all that all otherwise
you know what you have to do then you've
got to hire a lawyer to do it
the lawyer's gonna have to go through
all your email and figure out what they
what they're entitled to and what
they're not based on these these demands
and it is gonna get expensive otherwise
i suppose you can be like i don't have
the money i can't do it and then i don't
know what they'll do maybe take all of
your emails maybe try and come after
everything you own say okay then we'll
take everything not like you own but
like all of your private data they would
have to get a search warrant though like
with a subpoena like you don't like
subpoenas are a lot of the times it
depends on what agency does it under
what authority but well it's it's
congress yeah subpoenaing well it's not
just that it's also the federal
government pressing charges on a lot of
the people surrounding january 6th inc
including owen troyer that has an open
case against him and an open
investigation by the federal government
against them because allegedly he was
near uh the capital and i think correct
me if i'm wrong i think there's videos
of jones outside saying hey you guys are
being set up stop engaging stop fighting
um i mean that video alone in itself
again love love or hate him there's
video of him saying don't do this let's
be non-violent that that should
exonerate him from a lot of this what
are the other things beating the actual
like case if it's criminal they're gonna
need a search it's not criminal though
it's not it's not owen troyer it is
yeah yeah so this is this is the january
this is congress issuing a subpoena for
information for records
so this means
jones has to file a lawsuit to stop them
from getting access to his records or
whatever because you know it'll happen
they'll get access to his records there
will be nothing in there incriminating
but there will be embarrassing things
that will get leaked to the press of
course taken out of context they'll
they'll manipulate the evidence like
they do with with uh he's got to be able
to join his fourth amendment right to
some degree he has a obviously a very
strong reasonable expectation of privacy
you know what i'm saying so that i mean
he's got to be
yeah i i really doubt they'd be able to
get access to it i can make it simple
for everybody is uh use end-to-end
encryption and use vpns yeah and tell
them to get a warrant yeah but what it
is
like an example to say hey you know what
here's an example if what not to do
let's use alex jones
i hope not i mean i i think he has the
ability and the resources to get a
lawyer but man
they should not like he has a serious
reasonable expectation of privacy in his
emails phone communication et cetera
like you you because i've cause here's
the thing i've done title three
intercepts like i've done those cases
where a title three intercept is when
you listen to a phone real time right or
to get someone's emails or whatever it
takes an enormous amount of probable
cause to get into that stuff now i'm not
sure you said it's not a criminal case
you know but regardless he's still gonna
have an expectation of privacy and if
the government's going to come in and
try to get your information fourth
amendment man and yeah they're gonna
need some kind of
serious stuff to be able to get well it
depends on what kind of judge signs off
at on it because if we remember the
edward snowden glenn greenwald days we
found out that judges
uh blankly just generally signed
everything over allowing federal
agencies to spy on of course the
american influence of the world changes
yes
you said you you did what title three
interceptions yeah so that's literally
like you're listening in and you can
hear the phone ring and then like oh how
does it work or can you hear them if the
phone's not being active no you can't so
so here's the thing like and there's
there's different spectrums of this but
title three is when you're listening to
a phone like for a criminal case right
which you're they don't know your
eavesdropping yeah they don't they don't
know but this when i did it you know
most of the time when the government
does it's for drug cases right what i'm
saying so it was a drug investigation
that i did and you were listening to it
now i will tell you guys and anyone will
tell you this an affidavit to to get
probable cause for a title three
intercept you need more probable cause
to listen to someone's phone than to
arrest them wow i'll say that again yeah
you need you need more probable cause to
listen to the phone to arrest them
because the thing is is you need to
establish that the phone is used for
some kind of criminal activity and to be
able to do that you have to gather
evidence to show that that phone is
using criminal activity a lot of the
times it's beyond the threshold of an
arrest sorry have you ever uh dealt with
someone using encryption
like would you listen to signal phone
calls
well
a better a better question is voip right
yeah so if someone dials a number and
presses go that's what you're typically
hitting right so
i never did on end-to-end encryptions i
always did on phones but um well that
and encrypt would just be like i got
signal on my phone yeah like whatsapp or
signal or television that's not going
through a phone company you know what i
mean so you'd have to go to facebook or
whatever and be like we want access to
this and to direct to this line you know
what i mean so i'm not aware at this
point so i can't speak on it in an
educated fashion but i will tell you
that when i did them we did them on
phones
and you know it's it's not that hard
because a lot of guys they would just
like use regular phones like cell phones
they would use cell phones yeah they
would use burner phones and they would
change the phone number often but so you
got to get access to these phone
companies or is this like
yeah i mean yeah you would you would go
through the phone companies to do it but
you would have to have like an enormous
amount of probable cost to do but this
is criminal remember so like when you're
doing like a criminal case it has
different you know sets and procedures
than like let's say a fisa court you
know what i'm saying that's like more
national security related you know
that's you know
classified stuff i didn't deal with that
side ever really and the reason why is
because of the pain in the end let's
let's take it to the meme territory we
got this story from the washington post
quote we are closer to civil war than
any of us would like to believe new
study says this is from barbara f walter
university of california at
san diego serves on a cia advisory panel
called the political instability task
force that monitors countries around the
world and predicts which of them are
most at risk of deteriorating into
violence by law the task force can't
assess what's happening with the within
the united states but walter a longtime
friend who has spent her career studying
conflicts in syria lebanon northern
ireland sri lanka the philippines rwanda
and golden nicaragua and elsewhere
applied the predictive techniques
herself to this country her bottom line
is that we are closer to civil war than
any of us would like to believe she lays
out the argument in detail on her new
book now i'll pause here could she just
be trying to sell a book she's an expert
on civil war she wants people to read
about her area of expertise she sees
conflict in this country and then tells
everybody and then they eat it up or let
me read this
they're going to say indeed the u.s has
already gone through what the cia
identifies as the first two phases of
insurgency the pre-insurgency and
incipient conflict phases and only time
will tell whether the final phase open
insurgency began with the sacking of the
capital by donald trump supporters on
january 6. uh i would like to interject
good friends at the washington post let
me just add a sentence and only time
will tell whether the final phase open
insurgency began with the sacking of
cities across the country by black lives
matter and antifa following the george
floyd incident
you see they totally they totally skip
over that and act like we didn't deal
with a hundred plus days of violent
ridings and dozens dead however
this is the point i want to get to
is this woman who is a cia advisor who
tells them when other countries are
going to break down in a civil war is
she just selling a book or is this legit
that's a very good question because you
could be absolutely right it could be
sensationalistic it could be hyperbolic
but there are signs that do prove some
merit in her conversation now the
comment that i would add to this if
there is one government secretive agency
that knows about civil war it's the one
that has been spreading civil wars all
around the world and that of course is
the cia which they have been doing all
over latin america all over the you know
asian countries all over the middle east
so so i mean obviously she comes from a
perspective where she also has
information where she's privy to that we
don't know anything about so when you
look at the information
that she's able to declassify the
databases she's able to go into she
might be seeing something that that that
we're not allowed to know that could be
still classified that does show this
kind of bigger partisanship this kind of
bigger conflict brewing because we've
been talking about it for a very long
time and and the conditions that create
this kind of partisanship uh big tech
social media and the corporate media
they work in tandem to divide people
politically those two ingredients that
that fuel for this fire isn't stopping
it's only getting more powerful it's
only becoming more readily available and
it's only becoming something that we
can't avoid even more so the conditions
that create these civil war-like aspects
they're not going away they're only
becoming stronger i'll throw it to the
january 6th story we were just talking
about
when you've got an overtly political
politicized government you know body
issuing subpoenas on a and going after
with legal power and criminal charges
against former members members of the
for of the previous administration i'm
like dude it's wild you know man i've
been talking about this for a long time
and i i'm not saying i know for sure
exactly what will happen but at a
certain
point i really want to swear and i'm
going to do it at a certain [ __ ]
point man at a certain
[ __ ] point okay i said it twice all
right just so you know i'm serious right
after it starts with me being like hey
look people are beating each other in
the streets and this ideology is you
know this divide is getting worse when
you've got
what happened with george floyd protest
riots
several dozen dead when you get january
6th when you have
a panel of establishment politicians
using government power to cr to file
criminal charges
against members of the previous
administration for the love of god
this country is being ripped apart and
it's at the highest possible levels you
you throw away everything else you throw
away the january 6 you show it you throw
away the riots you throw away you
pretend like none of that ever happened
and you come out and you say that there
is a panel members of congress who are
issuing subpoenas against the previous
executive branch's administration and
trying to put them in prison like steve
bannon now they're saying they want
criminal charges against mark meadows
they are literally trying to imprison
the previous administration and it was
these same people who claimed trump was
the bad guy for saying lock her up in
2016. and it was funny and he didn't do
anything the dude didn't even fire fauci
but i will absolutely state trump was
definitely a part of this this sundering
in the united states but but i'm going
to say one more time we don't need to
talk about antifa we don't need to be
talking about proud boys we can just
talk about members of congress who are
who are filing subpoenas against members
of the administration and members of the
media you don't have to like alex jones
he is a media personality and as much as
people don't want to don't want to hear
me say it i'm going to say it alex jones
runs a news organization
now you can hate him which is protected
under the first amendment that's right
and now they're coming after him they're
filing experience and and this is what
alex is arguing that he's got a first
amendment right here he does he does but
look at what is happening man they have
lost the plot i mean you look at the
stuff they're talking about with joe
manchin they're like one man who's the
real president is it joe manchin or is
it joe biden mentions a senator from
west virginia when was he gonna be on
your side no they demand fealty just
because joe manchin is a democrat they
demanded that he do whatever they want
him to do and when he doesn't
man they're going absolutely insane
against him claiming that he that body
needs to slam the boot down i'll tell
you this man every step of the way we
have seen dramatic escalations and what
is leading to this country being ripped
apart and we are watching it right now
and then when a cia advisor professor
lady comes out and she's like yeah it's
happening it's trump's fault by the way
but it's happening i'll be like it
doesn't matter if she thinks it's
trump's fault what matters is she thinks
that it's happening because you've got a
bunch of people who now think it's
happening here's another crazy thing too
you said earlier you said a grand jury
and was convened simply to indict trump
you know yeah that's right that's crazy
because so here's the thing about grand
juries grand juries typically
like they they've been working together
for you know weeks or months on end and
they've seen and heard a bunch of cases
the fact that they're convening a grand
jury solely
for
donald trump is crazy to me that's
that's wild because that's not normal
that's out of protocol let's let's let's
let's let's call let's call that
political and um a bit hyperbolic in a
sense i i i'm sure they'll tell you well
the scope of our investigation is fraud
into the trump administration or
something like that but we got the story
man yeah this is this this is this has
been news for the past couple months
that high profile or i should say like
that that individuals working within the
trump administration including
journalists have been subpoenaed to
testify on a grand jury to to indict
donald trump
there that and now it is being
speculated he will be indicted and if
he's indicted he will not be able to run
in 2024. wow the nation.com which is a
leftist publication said donald trump
will not be running for president 2024
something's that effect and the first
paragraph is donald trump will be
indicted for fraud and this will prevent
him from running the witch hunts is real
just fraud let me let me ask you you
have experience with grand juries maybe
a little bit yeah yeah how often do they
retire that's why that's why this is
weird to me because here's the thing the
federal court system everyone is in it
so
it would happen all the time i'd go into
grand jury i'd present my case right
some drug case whatever it may be and
then there'd be an fbi agent come after
me he'd go and do bank robbery then
there'd be a d agent he'd come in and do
a drug case there'd be an atf agent come
in and do somebody for a phone and
possession so we all would use the same
grand jury which is weird to me because
that grand jury will hear hundreds of
cases over the span of a few months
that's how grand jury works at the
federal system and then you come in you
testify you tell the facts of your case
you're in there with your prosecutor you
step out your prosecutor comes out true
bill bang and then you get your this is
state level just to clarify oh it's
state yeah new york state state yep
so
so i'll tell you this that's very
interesting so that tells me that the
feds probably didn't want it and it went
to the state because any ausa would love
to do to do a case like this especially
where new york exactly is this is this
southern yeah so so it's probably new
york city so it falls under southern
district of new york which is a very
aggressive prosecutorial office it's
actually one of the best in the country
in the southern district of new york
they have said they've done all the big
mafia cases they do the big racketeering
cases etc so they do big sexy cases like
this so i'm surprised that the feds
didn't take so that tells me they
probably didn't want it and this they
said you know what we'll run with it
with in your experience i know fed's
different from state but how what
percentage
do they were like what percentage of of
grand juries of like cases are returned
as indictments almost if you're going 95
yeah because because by the time here's
how how tight the reason why the federal
system doesn't lose is because by the
time you take a case to an ausa and you
present it and you guys gather your
evidence and you actually have enough to
indict that prosecutor's ready for trial
guys
at the federal system
they're ready for trial that's why the
feds rarely lose because prosecutors
don't take cases unless they know
they're going to win they don't want to
go to trial they want to win so and so
if they don't take it this tells me
right now it probably tried to go
federal they said hell no we're not
going to win this thing and then they
say you know what we'll take it so
i got to say i
very interesting grand juries are not
like like full-on trials you know where
it's difficult and there's it's
non-adversarial this means that the
state walks into a bunch of people and
says here's what they're going for
they're claiming that donald trump
inflated the value of his buildings to
secure loans which is fraud something
that affects okay so i just want to
clarify with the state system i don't
know how often the grand jury convenes
but i know at the federal level they
typically go for a few weeks to a few
months my understanding is that grand
juries almost always issue indictments
because they're not looking yeah they
always do almost right because they're
looking for a preponderance of evidence
so that means someone from the state is
going to walk across
probable cause because it's criminal if
it's go if so so if i thought a grand
jury just needs a little bit more than
probable cause no no probable cause so
so to return a criminal indictment yes
wow probable cause so so at the federal
level i mean regardless the united
states is probable cause right you need
probable cause to effect an arrest right
but for an indictment or a criminal
complaint whatever charging document you
want to use in information it's always
probable cause but um
but the fact that the state didn't take
it i mean sorry the feds didn't take it
is alarming to me because normally they
would do something like this so what
probably happened is this this the feds
are rarely going to charge a charge that
the state is also going to charge so for
example if the feds wanted to do a fraud
case they would deconflict with the
state and then one of them would take it
so the fact that the feds don't have it
in the state has it tells me probably
went to the state they did a grand jury
convened and then they uh and then they
presented the case to the grand jury the
state system is a little bit different i
just i just confirmed it you're right
it's probable
trump's getting indicted
so that's crazy this is the plan so that
he can't run because yeah on purpose
that's the point that could be it
there's there's there's there's no way i
would ever believe it otherwise and
there's so many people i got i got a i
covered this you know like last week and
i get these emails from salty you know
democrats or whatever anti-trump people
and they're like no his crimes are
finally catching up to him and i'm like
oh sh
if the dude's been this active
everywhere for this long you think they
wouldn't have come after him for
anything he was doing they're coming
after him because
trump
i guess the argument is he was obsessed
with the net worth the value of his
properties and so he inflated their
value okay well are you going to explain
to the grand jury that property values
are nebulous
like if i were to ask you like your
property values how do you determine the
property value
an appraisal but that's always it
changes with all the time and you can
get a different appraiser and give you a
different number for sure exactly so
they're coming after trump basically
because he was like you got a building
worth 500 million and he goes ma'am you
know probably worth 550 you know because
we did improvements on it i'm gonna get
a loan and they're like that's fraud
it's like uh and it's commercial too so
it has even more checks and balances so
i would love you know what i want i
would love if they actually do uh follow
through and he gets charged and
everything else like that i would like
to read either the indictment or the
criminal complaint that was filed in
support well it was more than likely an
indictment because it convened a grand
jury so it's probably gonna be an
indictment it's not gonna be a criminal
complaint so let me just ask everybody
who's
doubting the idea of a civil war do you
think if donald trump is indicted and
can't run that his supporters that
people on the right are gonna be like
i'll say this
it's because you mentioned some
fantastic points earlier about all the
things going on let's add to that the
fact that the
uh you know inflation is here you know
what 40 to 50 percent of the u.s
currency in circulation right now was
printed in the last 18 months
let's talk about the financial side too
yeah you know fiat currency nowadays is
is literally dwindling hyperinflation is
gonna rear its ugly head any time now
bloomberg said spend your paycheck as
soon as you get yeah like it's it's
crazy so so you got the polarization
between the two parties right between
the democrats and the and the
republicans you got this craziness that
went down at capitol hill you got the
fbi over here going after dudes for
misdemeanors you know what i'm saying to
try to send a message you got them
trying to indict trump by the state you
know clearly the feds didn't want to
take it out of the most aggressive
federal prosecutorial office in the
country by the way and
i mean yeah th this insane i wouldn't be
she's not crazy is this woman from the
cia is not crazy because there's a lot
of things in play here yeah look in in
2017 i was like man if this kind of
ideological you know conflict escalates
it's going to reach the highest levels
of government and people have repeatedly
said i was crazy i was crazy i was crazy
i was crazy now most people i think who
say that are typically on the left
because they just don't they're like nah
the establishment's the best it'll never
happen the security state now look where
we are
not look where you are you brought up a
very important point because financial
problems do lead to conflict whether
external or internal you look at
historically a lot of economic upheaval
was right before there was a major fight
that happened so that's another aspect
to kind of look at here but this uh
barbara f walter this cia political
scientist also said that it's the
erosion of democracy that brings us
closer to civil war and she says that
we're in between a democracy and a
autocracy and occasionally democracy is
what she called it
and she specifically talked about how
there's a big separation within the
military how three former retired
military generals are talking about how
there's a major split in there and how
there could be a potential coup d'etat
or civil war within the military that
could make this into an actual hot water
let's pull this up we got the story from
the washington post
three retire retired generals the
military must prepare now for a 2024
insurrection this is paul d eaton a
retired u.s army major general and
senior adviser to vote vets antonio m
taguba retired army major general
general with 34 years of active duty
service stephen m anderson is a retired
brigadier general who served in the u.s
army for 31 years now i want to read a
little bit what they say
but i want to i want to point out
we had the boston globe reporting
uh just before around around the
election time this past this last year
that john podesta
said that he had he or he was advising
the west coast to secede from the union
if donald trump wins
i think we may have just bought some
time
i think i think these next few years i
think a lot of people just didn't like
donald trump and they said oh okay 100
republicans are biased
i mean what i mean is republicans aren't
going to be the ones to succeed they're
not the fervent ideologues yeah that the
left is the left goes and smashes and
destroys and burns things down the
moment you get one day of one you know
bad riot they act like the apocalypse is
happening and that's what they're doing
right now right so what the washington
what these generals are saying is like
oh no i can't believe on january 6-7
they say january 6 a disturbing number
of veterans that's right and active duty
members what they're basically saying is
the military is split and what happens
come 2024 when election happens it gets
disputed again and then
half the military says this side's right
the other half says this side's right yo
welcome to a civil war and i'll i'll
i'll accentuate this
five states right now are refusing
vaccine mandates and being told by the
the federalized you know the the
generals running the national guard the
federal level or the you know the bind
administration
you have to do this or else and they're
like nope national guard state
so we're watching this this this
fracture already five states do you know
so i i know texas oklahoma let me
let me pull it up
five uh states national guard
that's crazy though yeah like it's gonna
be a standoff between those that are
vaccinated that aren't yeah i mean
there's so many things in play here man
we can even add in the fact that like
the family unit in the united states in
general is crumbling you know divorce
rates are at the highest have ever been
you know there's more single people
before it's five more states so it's
oklahoma so here we go we got oklahoma
wyoming iowa alaska nebraska and
mississippi and now texas
i was going to add to your point i don't
think it's going to be the vaxxers
versus the anti-vaxxers i think it's
going to be the double vaxxers versus
the quadruple
gillian baxters that the civil war is
going to be happening from my
perspective yeah there's going to be
like bill maher right yeah bill maher
got he got the the full dose by the time
it was a full dose now i guess it's not
he's not but he got two shots so it's
going to be the bill maher people being
like we already got vaccinated we're not
doing it again and it's going to be the
the mega vaxxers who are on their like
18th shot because it's been you know a
couple of years and they're going to be
like you're not up to date
i mean and the whole issue with the
vaccine man is that typically you need
at least what a decade to perfect you
know all these other vaccines that we
haven't placed for all these other
diseases you know they were worked on
and formulated and perfected within a
decade you know at bare minimum you got
this thing in a year well which is why
they got to keep punching sure i will
counter by saying mrna the the the
precur like the beginnings of it was in
the 80s
but not specifically for covid now
here's my here's my big thing right i
don't i i don't know how to argue
scientific research you know what i mean
like none of us work in a lab none of us
can know for sure so i always i always
follow i'm saying like all the other vex
most of your other vaccines were like
you know perfected within a decade
whereas like on this one we did it in a
year different technologies it's like
but but it leads to a lot of people
saying they want long-term data on it
but i don't want to rehash that because
i'm trying to you know we'll keep it
focused on yeah but the divide here is
real because there are some people in
the military saying i will comply with
biden's mandates some people saying they
won't comply that's already one divide
that's that doesn't even include the
political divide the social divide the
economical religious two as well the
religious divide i think they're just
literally making concepts and ideas up
about human beings to see how further
they could divide people because at the
end of the day i do believe a lot of
this kind of is divide and conquer i do
believe a lot of this is centralized but
the the national guards in other states
saying hey we're not going to go along
with what you want us to do with our own
bodies is big and a sign of this kind of
civil uh conflict that we're seeing the
cia lady talk about for sure i think
there's an agenda being pushed here and
uh the more they can divide us and see
how we you know manage between ourselves
and we destroy ourselves to better for
them because they want to conquer and
overall having a one power and one i
want to say one source you say yes or no
to if you complain or goodbye that's
cool so who is who's doing it who's
trying to divide us is it china honestly
well there's fourth generational warfare
there's fifth generational warfare
there's a lot of other multinational
corporations yeah and some people would
argue it is china some people would
argue it's the multinational
corporations that made china as
prominent as they are that sent the
slave jobs there that are connected to
the true billionaire class that's
connected to the banking class so
there's a lot of very powerful
institutions very powerful people but
then you get into the realms of
speculation i don't want to get into
into speculating here uh because we
could go on days and talk about sure
personally believe but i think it is
clear that we are being divided yeah
more than we ever have been and it's
turning in a nasty nasty way that we
have to try to stop at all cost but it's
not stopping it's only let's say this in
china is that there's you know we're
talking about the civil war a war with
china is extremely probable you know
what i mean like china is
buying at the chop you know i'm saying
they're buying up the bit right now to
go after taiwan they go after taiwan
well taiwan for a lot of you guys that
no i'm sure you know this they make a
bunch of our chips that are used for
technology and if china was to take over
taiwan that would put us in a very
difficult position where we would
probably have to come in and act and
defend and help taiwan and it's like uh
you know and that would put us in a
pretty bad spot because you don't want
to go to war with china they're our
biggest trader and already they're
talking about building a chip plant in
texas i believe yes because they are
trying to we know what's coming yeah
it's coming
they're gonna invade taiwan there's no
doubt about it they've been waiting for
for years to do it here's the here's the
issue i take with uh with like this you
know they're trying to divide us i'm
just like trying to figure out who is
they because when you've got the
military split when you've got 30 000
active duty military saying no to the
vaccines when seven states are saying
they will not abide by this for the
national guard and i'm like is it is it
the the establishment like is it the
democrats the uniparty and now there's
like a populist wave that's rejecting
this because if that's the case then the
division is natural it's populist versus
elitist or is there a larger
international group like luke mentions
like multinational corporations who are
pitting populists and helping fund these
campaigns to create division in the u.s
or is it is it actually just that there
is a a psychotic cult ideology growing
in this country
that manifests itself in in violence and
ignorance and then there are regular
people who are trying to make you know
trying to live trying to get by and when
you try you know you know and and i'll
accept some of the criticism in this
regard because it's frustrating to me
when i try over and over again to reach
an olive branch out to these people and
what do we get we got what happened here
last week anger rage on both sides to be
fair but if i'm like okay i'll give you
that point i'll give you that point i'll
give give you that point will you agree
with me on this and they say no and they
say screw you and they threaten more
violence at a certain point you know
look we're we are not the this is this
show is not the trump maga hat cue
anything like that this is the show
where i'm talking to a dude who's very
lefty very woke and i'm like i i agree
with you on systemic racism i agree with
you on those issues do you agree with me
on individual rights and they say no
if i keep giving olive branches out and
they keep taking and taking and taking
so i don't know if this isn't if this if
there is like an elite group trying to
do this on purpose or this is what
happens when you get a cult ideology
that is fervent angry and ignorant and
you get people who
are
i guess opposed to that and unwilling to
compromise with it is not respected
anymore independent thinking is no
longer respected it's like you can't
have an opinion on something it's like
oh you think
you think trump did a good job oh well
you're a bigot you know what i'm saying
they're immediately going to subscribe
you to to that end just because of their
personal feelings whereas like hey you
did it so a terrible job as a president
let me ask you real quick
people talk about all the time it might
be illuminati it might be bilderberg who
knows what it is right i'm just saying
when all the chaos comes order so look
like trojan horse right they get you
from the inside uh inside out i'm just
saying like in terms of what we're going
around the future like let's be real
here we're not getting any better we're
not getting we're not coming together as
one we're dividing between each other
yeah but race you know religion all this
stuff why is this happening there's
somebody out there pushing an agenda i
don't know who it is but it's causing
divide and once that happens at some
point
just really quickly tim you you laid out
three hypotheses right
all of them could be through uh true at
the same time so we have to also
entertain those larger ideas and
spectrum of understanding here because
it could be a natural divide that some
people are playing off that of course
also benefits china as well so all three
parameters could be at play here and we
could be trying to figure out we
shouldn't try to pinpoint exactly
you know like this is exactly how it is
because it's almost impossible to figure
out there's a lot of disinformation
there's a lot of fake information that's
being deliberately released out there to
confuse people to make people go crazy
uh going down the rabbit hole we don't
have to go down the rabble we see the
problems we have to do everything we can
to prevent them because these problems
are getting real they're getting
dangerous and they're going to be have
significant ramifications for everyone's
life very soon if they already don't
here's here's the challenge
because because luke you sound a lot
like ian
so you know ian he's on holiday shout
out ian um
he likes to say
you know we got to bring people together
man we can't allow this division and i'm
like that's right that proud boy wearing
the maga hat needs to throw down that
shield run up to the antifa guy the
antifa guy needs to take his mask off
pull down the hoodie they should run to
each other and embrace in a nice arm
lock and say we're in this together and
that'll happen right that's gonna is is
that is that gonna happen sounds good
but it's never gonna happen unless it's
in a pepsi commercial unless it's a
pepsi commercial so this is what i'm
saying
we can invite these people on the show
they won't do it i i i sent a son [ __ ]
a message i was like hey man would you
like to come on the show we'd love to
have you you know we'll pay for
everything just no response dude doesn't
owe me a thing okay he doesn't have to
come on the show but if we can't get
people to come on the show to talk about
these things then how do you actually
even work towards mending that divide
and worse still when we invite someone
on the show who is very much into
wokeness and as he described it the
black struggle and i tell him i agree
with you on all of these points and then
he still calls me names he still insults
me he still laughs me and calls calls me
a liar and all stuff you know at a
certain point i'm watching these high
profile individuals keep trying to
compromise and it doesn't work we are
dealing with zealotry whatever this side
is you know for us freedom independence
liberty you've got many conservatives
involved there is a live and let live
classical liberalism in there and
somewhat traditional liberalism and then
in the cult you have a shut up and do as
you're told or else
i don't know
what anyone can do at this point and i'm
sorry if it sounds pessimistic to
convince the maga hat waring trump
supporter with american flag to go up to
antifa and shake their hand and say
let's make this country a better place
because if even if that were to happen
the next step is antifa saying okay
let's tear down the american institution
let's burn the constitution let's get
rid of our court system and the trump
supporter guy is going to be like but
those are good things yeah yeah just out
to your point tim i don't believe
there's a way we can ourselves can come
together as one however maybe through
fair or through like a tragic event it
might bring us together i don't know
what it's going to be but us is like you
know either trump supporters or like you
know antifa us we're not we're not going
to do it by ourselves to be a
outside cause they make us come together
but i don't know what it's gonna be i'll
say this simply put
there's a lot of we we address a lot of
like problems right now in in the west
in general in the united states in
particular you know we got the issue
with money right 40 40 of the us
currency in circulation was printed in
the past 18 months right there so we got
a financial problem now we have also a
family problem you know we have
the nuclear family has almost been
destroyed united states you know we we
how many kids come from you know two
parent households with both parents that
were there by their biological parent
eighteen percent now rare yeah eighteen
percent
eighteen percent yeah some of the latest
extremely rare right which we know that
nuclear families are the backbone of a
strong economy so you have that right
divorce rates are through the roof you
got masculinity in general which is like
getting thrown to the waistline hey
let's you know think with our feelings
and let's operate off feelings and not
logic and ration and you know toxic
masculinity all those other bs and then
you know you got the polarization
between the two um you know political
parties there's and then on top of that
you've got the looming issues with china
and russia right you got the russian
probe which also divided the country
that was another uh example of a trojan
horse yeah and then you got the the
looming issues with china with taiwan
and it's just there's so many problems
here that it's like just like oh man i
think the biggest one is the mass
hypnosis the kind of brainwashing that
happens to the average american out
there whether it's on social media or
through the corporate media they get a
different
bastardized reality than of course other
people do they get put in echo chambers
they get radicalized and i think you
know the answer is not easy but it
doesn't mean we should stop doing what
we're doing i think we are having an
effect i think we should always try to
to strive to do the best we can to help
open people's visions we might not
always do it but we should also
understand we're playing for the middle
person we're not playing for for antifa
we're not playing someone who's totally
radicalized and totally insane and crazy
we're playing for the person the average
person the majority of people who are
sitting back and watching what's going
on because those people are the ones
historically that do make the big
decisions that do create the situations
that do change societies it's the people
in the middle who don't want to get
involved that actually end up doing the
most and that's why we got to play to
them that's why we get to be fair and
then i think we we shouldn't break the
rules like they break the rules bro
those from my perspective well i
certainly think
you know all the points you brought up
are hitting the nail on the head with
the hammer i mean kids not being born
two-parent homes the economy is based on
children yes and like lowest birth rates
right now yeah and china has is the
opposite they have a strong family unit
they they you know they they take cri
pride and uh masculinity you know they
actually they they they don't allow porn
into their country or rock music or rap
music or degenerate type you know social
media stuff so you know they take
proactive steps to protect their side to
society from degeneracy so go ahead
which side of the political conflict and
there are sides let's be real within it
there's a bunch of different factions
you know libertarians and conservatives
are very different a lot of opinions
which which side is pro family and which
side is opposed to the sen to the
nuclear family
it's pretty clear it's pretty
very obvious it's very clear like even
me
who's who i'm a childless 35 year old
i'm in a relationship but no kids can
recognize the importance of having kids
and i can understand why conservatives
looking at data are correct then you get
black lives matter they say they want to
disrupt the nuclear family then you get
the left which is very much tearing down
cultural and you know uh cultural rules
and it's like i'll be the first to say a
lot of traditions are dumb and bad and
we should do away with them and some of
them are good and we should keep them
you don't just you know burn everything
to the ground but it's very clearly left
and right and that being said to address
what you're saying luke luke there's no
middle ground
there's none look at this look at this
i'm not saying there's middle ground i'm
saying there's people in the middle who
don't want to get involved that are
watching and those are the people we
should play to i'm not saying so well
let's clarify that
almost nobody is in whatever can be
perceived to be as a middle what we have
right here is joe biden's job approval
according to civics with 141 000
responses what you're seeing is party
affiliation independent 26 approval if
we go to republican obviously it's going
to be in the gutter with 2 percent
approval 96 disapproval and if you go to
democrat it's 76 percent approval but
what does this show it shows that
democrats overwhelmingly still approve
of biden they're losing a lot of support
disapproval is going up but independents
lean heavily towards where republicans
are
when you look at pew's data on the
political tribes the group called the
stressed sideliners these are people who
are not political lean right politically
and the reason is we like watching
offensive comedy we like watching
comedians and making jokes we don't want
to live under a boot we like family we
like christmas we like the holidays
and we like having our money and not
have it taken by taxes i mean that's
true too you know everyone what do they
say everyone's a conservative until
they're i'm sorry everyone's liberal to
their first paycheck exactly
so my point is
there's obviously still some undecideds
the stressed sideliners or whatever but
even they lean right and so the issue is
if we are if we are a show where
we we we don't say cal right now as a
hero we defend him acting in
self-defense and but we've not you know
like that that's a big you know
conservative right-wing trump supporter
a lot of those people are outright say
they say in the chat i respect their
right to say i understand why they say
it for me i'm like
it's a difficult situation of political
conflict and there's you know this is a
complicated situation but kyle right now
was certainly acting in self defense and
in the right 100 but anyone else that
doesn't like it it's the most clear-cut
self-defense case i've ever seen in my
life but so here's my point right
if you're talking about the regular
people then i can tell you a regular
person's gonna look at that and be like
self-defense how do we know because the
jury was a group of regular people who
said not guilty across the board
but
exclusively like the entirety of the
left from leftists to the establishment
save destiny the streamer they were all
saying it was murder they were lying
about what he did and so he might my
point is regular people he killed black
people that's right what i'm saying like
it just goes to show like the gross lack
of knowledge and awareness of people
when they look at big cases like this
they don't look at the facts they look
at what someone put on twitter or what
someone thinks feelings emotions
feelings and emotions they don't look at
the facts and that's ridiculous that's
the quote unquote left and i'm saying
the left because before reals it
includes leftists and it clues down
includes the establishment democrats but
libertarians independents moderates
republicans traditional conservatives
religious conservatives all knew the
truth
they all knew the truth now there's of
course there's always going to be people
on
on the right who are believing dumb
crazy conspiracy things too my my point
is
the left is clearly in some kind of
matrix
they they believe well they have their
their moral framework is is or i should
say lack thereof they have none they
don't believe in the innocent until
proven guilty they fire people from jobs
and accusations they want people
imprisoned on accusations they burn
buildings down when they don't get their
way when it comes to this kind of stuff
libertarians moderates independents
centrists right-wingers conservatives
they don't do any of that stuff
so when i when we come out here and we
go on the show and we say something like
kyle written house acted in self-defense
jury said so evidence shows it seven
witnesses said it
then
we're not going to convince anyone on
the left ever
that we are right they're just going to
say you're racist yep so
my main point is
when you know bringing it back to the
issue of family and everything i think
the divide is is so extreme in this
country we call it a political divide we
call polarization i think that's wrong i
think it is a grand canyon
there there's i i do not believe there's
going to be a way
like even even that guy hawk newsom the
black lives matter guy in new york who
went to a trump rally and they cheered
for him and he said i want you know to
make life better and everyone's like we
do we do
then he starts expressing his opinions
on what will make life better and all of
a sudden you're like
bro if you're if you're saying you want
to burn the constitution yeah that's not
going to happen right i'm never going to
shake someone's hand in that capacity
yeah there i don't think there's a way
you get antifa black lives matter and
then you know even regular americans who
like christmas and family to shake hands
and agree on how to move forward i think
family could be the solution though and
you know a lot of powerful people when
they want to enact change they if they
do it intelligently they have a process
of doing it they they do it very slowly
generation two two steps forwards one
step back if you look at a lot of these
kind of crazy leftist they believe in
the need not to have children
in benefit of the environment you look
at a lot of them they're incapable of
reproducing because of their loan low
testosterone efforts they're incapable
of producing because of choices they
made with their bodies that have
negatively impacted them whether
abortions or others so so a lot of
people on the left can't and won't be
having babies a lot of people on the
right
will a lot of people who do believe in
family values will so there there might
be an aspect to this of saying if we all
have families we could teach them morals
and principles and virtues that actually
matter and transcend a lot of the
hypocrisy craziness and nonsense when it
comes to this larger depopulation agenda
that the left is predominantly affected
by and hurt by and i'll say this too the
family is is the backbone of a strong
economy you know what i'm saying you
need you need two parents you know and
there's an overwhelming amount of
evidence that shows that you know
children that come from single-parent
households have a higher likelihood of
being degenerate drug addicts criminals
etc and you need that father in place
you know to let you know that there are
consequences to your actions and punish
that bad behavior and then you need a
mother there to you know instill
nurturing values take care of you in
your childhood etc and then as you
become older and you hit adolescence
that's when your father comes in and
becomes an imperative part of your
development and we live in a society now
that says we don't need men men are
useless men are trash toxic masculinity
blah blah blah and what do we have we
have a bunch of degenerates a bunch of
spineless men you know we have
degenerate women that are running around
doing stupid things and rewards
fatherless homes exactly yeah with
financial information so
that's obviously a big cultural
component economically though let's make
it very very simple the economy is
driven by a need to support and sustain
kids yes like a lot of money goes into
my kid needs this my kid needs that my
kid wants this my kid wants that raising
kids yes when you get older you're gonna
work this is why they're saying you're
gonna own nothing you're gonna be happy
because without a kid what do you what
what do you need to strive for it's the
nfts yeah the forest leather boots of
agility and warcraft we're put on earth
to procreate that's why we are here we
are here to have offspring so you know a
huge human part of your fulfillment is
not met if you don't have children and
you know it's great that you know on the
right they tend to swing more towards
family values etc and that that's what's
needed the united states was built on
the back of the nuclear family you know
in the in the 20s the 50s all the
economic booms occurred from a man going
to work providing for his family you
know obviously times have changed you
know you need two parent household
whatever to make an income but the point
is is that a two-parent household with a
family is the backbone of the united
states how it became an economically my
humble opinion like there's a another
divide as well between the rich and the
poor there's no more middle class it's
pretty much going away and at this point
that was the nuclear family the middle
class but guess what taxes are going up
prices are going up inflation and
there's either rich or poor this is
going to cause even more divide because
now either the have-nots or the haves
that's that's my opinion yeah so
definitely uh it's definitely huge
polarization i agree i think the uh
if you look at where the left has gone
right so the left of my youth is is is
mostly considered right-wing now right
you know
but that's true like 10-15 years ago
like you know i mean just look at bernie
sanders yeah he's far left look look at
his opinions from 2008 you'd be like wow
that's a trump supporter yeah like
across the board you know we got to
bring our factories back and you close
the borders and it's like okay trump
yeah but you look at where the left is
today and they
they've overwhelmingly become
it's it's almost the epitome of the
seven deadly sins you know like like
it personified like name one of the
vices and they've got it you know i mean
envy right angry they're they're wrath
filled they're prideful they're lustful
they're greedy and don't get me wrong
the right has this too
but my point is
i'm thinking about these these comments
on twitter i'm thinking about these
articles that have been written by many
left-wing activists where they're like
who cares about where this country goes
i mean that's the core message of a lot
of what they're saying who cares what
happens
who happens who cares what happens to
humanity it's blind because one thing
especially when it comes to the criminal
justice system we got crazy quotes
running around here like believe all
women last time i checked you know men
and women fought for equality equality
means you are the same therefore you are
capable of lying just like a man and
last time i checked we live in a country
where it's you know guilty right it's
innocent until proven guilty not guilty
until proven innocent but if you're
going to run around and say believe all
women that's ridiculous you know what
i'm saying we had brett kavanaugh a
couple years ago
testifying right and for under oath in
front of everyone on some accusations
that were not from 40 years ago that no
one had proof of and no he did this to
me and her friends even denied it that
her friends denied it no witnesses no
nothing but we got a guy that's going to
be a supreme court justice basically in
a cloud world a clown circus where he
has to testify for his own innocence why
because he's going to be a supreme court
justice i get it he needs to be held to
the highest standard of law but at the
same time it's like yo come with some
facts before you're going to go ahead
and make a crazy accusation i'll i'll
put it this way you know a lot of people
a lot of people like to say you know
it's unfair you're taking the worst
examples of the left and the left does
it to the right and i'm like okay well
hold on a second
when we talk about like eric swalwell
right he tweeted we should ban people
from flying i'm not going to pretend
that every democrat wants that you know
but probably a lot of them don't agree
with that i'm not going to pretend that
every everyone on the left is taking
everyone's list
or and they're liberal gun owners they
exist too yeah but i will tell you that
what is true
overwhelmingly not absolutely is that
they believe in a fictitious reality
and then they believe in that fictitious
reality that everyone on the right are
truly the ones who live in the
fictitious reality
but the truth is russia gate was a lie
jesse smallette was a lie the covington
kids was a lie the cow written house
story was a lie
every day they are putting out lies
and i think what actually divides us is
are you in the matrix or are you outside
of it the red house case was was
terrible like it is so if you watch that
trial
it's clear-cut you know what i'm saying
like they they they were trying to like
mess this kid up man and everyone's
running around oh no well he killed
black people no he didn't people
you know what i'm saying but it's like
they're just trying to do and say
anything to to get a reaction they don't
even look at the facts they go off what
their friend says on twitter what
possible allegations are and this it's
crazy because it's
this country was
founded upon do
process man and you literally have a guy
that got acquitted
with beyond like
clearest cut case of self-defense i've
ever seen if that was tough
i am scared of the future to get a guy
like that that was clearly innocent you
look you look at what happens when we
bring on you know someone like this and
they say you defend
here's the fascinating thing and i i'll
just i'll just say it outright with ra
the rugged man when he came on
and again you know look as far as
anything goes with the the shenanigans
and the yelling at each other like me
yelling and hemming them like i i'm over
that but what i i do think is important
is
you know here's a guy
who told us we were supporting the cops
we were bootlicking over the ahmed
arbory case in the derek shoving case
when he was literally defending the
state in its entirety our issue was what
we said is
these specific individuals have rights
that are in question and he was like if
you defend a single police officer
you're a bootlicker and it's like but
you're supporting literal state
prosecution in the prison system which
i'm not a fan of i'm not a fan of any of
that
i'm a fan of individual rights but some
so that you know ultimately i'm not
trying to drag him specifically but it
was it's a fresh conversation and it's a
good example these are people who are
like you're the bootlicker i'm in favor
of state prosecution and i'm like why
are you cheering for the prosecutors why
are you literally cheering for more
people to go into car and to be
incarcerated i thought the left were the
ones that said the system is broken it's
it needs to be abolished but then as
soon as they have power on their side
they just use it to its fullest extent
and say don't question me
yeah my thing is you gotta you gotta be
on no one's side you gotta look at it
like okay what are the facts and what
does the law say simple as that man
you'll you'll find you're you're gonna
be you're gonna be in the cultural right
if that's the case yeah exactly just
like i said
russian
ukraine
covington kids trump throwing fish into
the koei pond all of these stories every
day just lie after lie after a lie over
and over and over again and certain a
certain point it's like if you are like
i'm not going to be on anyone's side i'm
going to look objective objectively at
the facts you know what's gonna happen
jack bosobics gonna be like you're
correct sir i disagree with you but
you're right and someone on the left is
gonna be like you're a conspiracy
theorist of course and you're gonna be
like but i just read i just read this
this report from new york times new york
times reported ukrainian court said that
ukrainians were interfering in the u.s
election the new york times published
that nope sorry that's a conspiracy
theory if you're if you're on the left
because you got to be in the matrix you
got to follow the narrative i was just
going to say you started to sound like a
white supremacist there for a little bit
i got my hood in the back somewhere
i'm gonna put it on after the show so
i'm gonna pull up this story right here
this is from cnn biden admin eyes a
potentially stark shift in messaging
around ending the pandemic so tomorrow
we're supposed to get a statement from
joe biden about what they're gonna do
but his his message was clear they say
quote for the unvaccinated we are
looking at a winter of severe illness
and death for the unvaccinated he said
it twice i guess for themselves their
families and the hospitals they will
soon overwhelm but there's good news if
you're vaccinated and you have your
booster shot you're protected from
severe illness and death now i don't
want to play any silly games dragging
joe uh joe biden this is not his
administration well i guess they say you
know this is biden's you know address of
the american people
saying that many people were like yo
it's just before christmas and you're
going to be like you're going to face
death and illness and everything but
people on the left are going to be like
he's just warning people as he should so
i'm not going to i'm not going to play
games and be like aha we don't like
biden so we criticize every single thing
he says i will tell you you will not
convince anyone
that
you know when biden said if you're
vaccinated and you have your booster
shot you're protected from severe
illness and death i want to make two
very important points i'm not a
scientist i can't tell you i'll make
three actually i can't tell you anything
about the research being done on this
stuff i got no idea you make sure you
talk to a doctor you know and trust get
a second opinion i can tell you that i
was interacting with someone on twitter
who said just got my third shot and then
i said are you gonna get your booster
and this guy responds i just said i got
my third shot i said no no i meant the
fourth shot because but i'm not trying
to be a dick like literally several
leftist publications have already said a
full vaccine dose is three shots and he
said it's a stupid conversation because
every year we get a flu shot and no one
asks you if it's your eight if it's your
18th my response to that is the flu
shots as i understand it are different
meaning every year they say here's the
dominant strain here's the vaccine for
this strain and a few others it might
not stop these other strains the covet
vaccine is one vaccine developed
specifically for the alpha strain and
now we're getting we're we're looking
for data on whether or not it will stop
omnicron as jovan likes to call it or
any other variant and if that's the case
joe biden is not doing anything by
saying this when you have this story
elizabeth warren vaxxed and vaccinated
and boosted tests positive for coven
corey booker positive for cronovirus
both elizabeth warren and cory booker
are vaccinated and boosted and then we
have jim cramer who of cnbc who said
he said that the military should
forcefully vaccinate people and he
posted a positive test now i'm not going
to tell you what or why that is i'll
tell you my theory on exactly what this
is i believe it is is infinitely more
likely
it infinitely likely or i should say
just simple put it simply
i believe all these people lied about
getting vaccinated whoa
okay
i i mean like look there's a photo of
elizabeth warren and they're putting a
needle in her arm yeah i think you've
got two potentials
the vaccine isn't working on the
variants the efficacy has waned to the
point where covid cases in new york are
breaking records
or
these specific politicians and
high-profile individuals who go on tv
and virtual signal about the vaccine
never got it someone's laying here yeah
and it it's funny because it's a
lose-lose either way because you're very
frustrated just just after this point as
well like okay
what's the the goal here because is it
control is it to like say okay you know
what do what they say or not and if if
that's the case then when does it stop
because this is just this is mouth it's
like okay vaccine or you might die or
maybe it could be like okay if we're in
power you don't do what i say you'll die
regardless so just like to me it's more
like control yeah there's a lot of
things going on on right now that are
totally breaking the official narrative
of what's going on here and that white
house memo was released by their chief
of staff not by joe biden but i mean it
sounded more threatening than warning
but their response to everything
happening is get boosted media get
boosted as they're running
sensationalistic fear-mongering articles
but of course as you mentioned tim cory
booker hunter walker elizabeth warren
the governor of maryland jim cramer most
cnn and buzzfeed employees all triple
vaxxed with boosters all of them
recently came down with this new
coven 19
sickness like what's going on cnn shut
their offices down
and cnn fired employees who were
unvaccinated so all of the employees at
cnn were vaccinated
hold on hold on boosted well done okay
i'm not a scientist i can't say vaccines
work or don't work clearly the only
thing that makes sense if that's true is
that every single one of these
high-profile democrats celebrities and
every employee at cnn faked getting the
vaccine i'll say this real quick here
i'll just say this and then the people
can think what they want the vaccine i
remember rolled out right around about a
year ago right the first first time
they're like listen just take the shot
you'll be good and then next thing you
know we're here a year later now we're
up to three shots and the people that
take the shots allegedly are still
getting the virus still passing the
virus basically doing all the things
that the vaccine was developed to keep
you from doing and
it's crazy it's like what's good how
many more vaccines are they going to
make how many more do you have to take
it's i think i think there's actually
maybe a a very very simple explanation
or that it's coveted
well yeah i am a little bit facetious
when i said obviously like is it one of
those but i think i think coverts become
endemic
it's going to be a yearly thing which
has been stated by many many people yeah
and the alpha vaccine that they got
under eua is slowly becoming not the
appropriate vaccine for whatever is you
know emerging now because the vi the
virus spreads i think i think the issue
is if the cdc comes out and just finally
says covet has become endemic it's never
going away
then the the establishment loses their
power all of a sudden people are going
to be like i guess i got to live my life
then yeah but if they maintain that
we're in a pandemic it'll never go away
then they will keep being able to force
people they will control people and i
gotta say i really don't think
i i that that the goal of the vaccine
mandates is vaccines i think it's social
credit systems yeah you're absolutely
right and from a logical point of view
from a medical point of view if you
really wanted to help people now you
would be dealing with early treatment
you would be dealing with accepting the
risk here uh helping the vulnerable but
what's happening is they're still on
this crazy insane journey to prevent
people from getting sick how why are you
doing this when clearly you have failed
and the more you do the more people get
infected and hurt here so from a logical
point of view this doesn't add up to to
help in new zealand clarify though i
don't know if it's more people are
getting it but certainly people are
still getting it i think the numbers
have went up especially under the bible
administration
what i mean i just don't want us to get
to the point of australia and new
zealand they can't even leave you know a
mile and a half two miles of their place
their ability to get food is controlled
yeah yeah
it's crazy let me let me tell you i'll
spin you a little tail so
i posted
hey look you know australia built these
quarantine camps then i said what's
going to happen is there's going to be a
protest they're going to claim it was a
super spreader event they got to put
these people in quarantine i got called
a conspiracy theory for that then they
started taking people and putting them
in these quarantine camps at first i
said it was an international arrival
bungalow now it's the police come to
your house and without due process take
you to the camps here's the best part i
was talking about the native america the
i'm sorry
the indigenous in australia the native
australians yes and uh i said
the minister of uh the north the
northern territory said you no longer
have the five reasons to leave your home
that means you can only leave your home
now for emergency medical treatment and
i said that quite literally means you
can't leave your house to go and get
food yep
and then what happens is they pull up
and say come with us we're taking you to
the camp and then these people try
escaping three teenagers escaped what
happens the latest response from
quillette this you know psychotic
publication that claims to be about
freedom was that tim poole lied because
while they can't leave their homes to
get food they're not being deprived the
government is delivering morning meals
to them and i'm like i said you can't
leave your house even to get food and
they're like but he's implying people
are starving i don't care if the
government fires food out of a cannon
through your window i don't care if they
bring you a filet mignon with grilled
asparagus and all of the
accompaniments yeah if you can't leave
your house to choose to get food on your
own we have certainly crossed that
threshold exactly that's where we're
going absolutely and the netherlands has
locked down for for another month right
now and and germany's talking about
making uh vaccines mandatory for
everyone forcing them on everyone this
is the german health minister that said
immediate forced vaccinations for the
entire population this is absolutely
crazy
before we get into all that
related to the cnn article about them
closing their offices and and working
from home i saw one of the best memes i
have ever seen in my life in relation
related to this story and it's the the
guy with the yellow jacket clasping his
hands behind the tree and it says lubin
tubin when he finds out that he gets to
work from home
and i have to say the creativity on the
internet is dirty absolutely it's not
it's not dirty yeah
he really likes working from home
i just want to add to that points well
this myself a little bit bass but uh it
was never about helping people become
better it's about control and if you
think about it right when does it end it
probably never will end however look
what's happening now control is
happening at least mention australia
other countries
at some point
what's the goal here and if you think
about this long term like this affecting
how we how we buy food how we how we use
money how we uh travel australians can't
even leave talk to each other how we
date how we interact with people it's
like a heavy
place and control now when once this
happens like what's the end goal my
thing is how do we stop it we can't so
what do you what what can we do create
our own communities and maybe thrive
that way but there's no way i disagree
with you i mean the governor of florida
came out and released a very strong
statement today saying we will not let
anybody lock you down take your jobs
ruin your business or close your schools
i don't care what biden says we're not
going to be following his mandates his
decrees which he's going to be
announcing in a few hours from now which
is supposed to be new restrictions on
the american people so people of florida
don't have to go through a lot of the
bull crap miami dade is a little see we
live in florida right the question is
how long and it's but the funny part is
that yes he's doing that right now but
pressure and you know every other state
doing it eventually you can only hold it
for so long and miami
well florida never kind of uh i mean
yeah we never we we never really closed
down yeah they never really closed out
but miami dade but you didn't close the
day
we definitely we closed and like miami
dade was the last county to open back up
now obviously the rest of florida you
know has their head on straight yeah but
miami-dade in general like we opened up
recently we just opened up a few months
ago you know fully so
yeah i mean it is what is but no florida
definitely is it's a good state to be
right now compared to other places hell
us coming to here you know to the dc
airport and i'm just seeing like you
know people running around with mass
everywhere i was like oh wow i've seen
this yeah you don't see this in florida
let's talk about what's happening in new
york city we got this story from
timcast.com new york proposes ending
religious exemptions inoculations
without parental consent and forced
removal of disease cases contacts and
carriers
changes to the state's public health
laws could mean more vaccine
requirements and new authority for the
governor here's what i love about this
story
this uh this right up here at
timcast.com is all 100 percent factual
and correct but it also brings up a very
important uh assembly bill from new york
and that's bill a four one six tim cass
writes the new york legislature will
also consider assembly bill a416 which
resembles the australian quarantine
camps that caught global attention
earlier this month
assemblyman and nick perry of brooklyn's
58th district proposed the removal and
detention of anyone with a communicable
disease that warrants the new york
governor to declare a state of health
emergency due to an epidemic the funny
thing is a bunch of fact checkers
claimed that when this story emerged in
january it was fake news and they said
the reason was the bill is from 2015.
they're not planning here's what they do
they say is there a law currently about
to be passed that would allow covid
patients to be indefinitely detained
false
there is a bill that would allow coveted
patients to be indefinitely detained but
it's for ebola
and it's never made it out of committee
anyway so it's fake news even though
it's true
there literally is a bill assembly bill
a416
since 2015 when it was introduced it's
gone to committee and then flopped it's
got no sponsors it doesn't go anywhere
but someone's certainly trying to make
it happen it would give the governor the
ability to just rendition you to take
you and put you wherever they deem fit
if they think you're a public health
threat
i'm not convinced it'll happen maybe it
is you know a little fear-mongery to be
bringing it up or whatever but if it's
there we ignore it and they do pass it
no one speaks about it then we'll regret
it yeah so what what can we do we have
to mention it exists and we've got to
tell people in new york do not let them
pass this otherwise one day they'll get
a knock on the door from the nypd the
the you know the scumbags who are
arresting people for not having vax
cards and then they're going to say come
with me
oh my god
yeah i mean the video and that's not too
far but what's been happening in new
york i mean we you see the videos all
over uh social media people going in to
panera bread saying hey i just want to
order some food police officers coming
in there acting like they're big bad
brave soldiers meanwhile they were
looking the other way during blm riots
they were twiddling their thumbs not
trying to get involved with it
if a man doesn't get government paper
permission to go to the panera bread oh
they're going to go right on top of them
arrest them lock them up and and rough
them up that's crazy so so i'll tell you
you know i point out that the police are
stomping on the middle class working
regular people
that they're trying to enforce that
they're literally enforcing
government-mandated medical procedures
and i'll tell you what what makes me
feel like there's there's never going to
be that handshake moment left or right
between the the the culture war because
i'm actually getting criticized from the
left for saying abolish the police
they say yeah but tim's only saying it
because the police are stomping on
conservative civil rights and i'm like
well i'm talking about working-class
people but they're like doesn't matter
we hate you and that's what it's all
about so if i see cops
walk in and arrest someone for
trespassing
why was he trespassing didn't have a
vaxcard it's it's it's it's complete bs
sorry i'm not going to defend these cops
furthermore in that video of the uh of
the guy getting arrested a female cop is
stepping all over the american flag she
takes out of a guy's hand throws it on
the ground and then i don't think she
was stomping it on purpose some people
said she was wiping her feet on it no
she's just walking all over it she
doesn't care
these are this is the nypd so you know
we had we've had libby emins tell us the
nypd wasn't enforcing this stuff well
they are now so if you live in new york
you you this is this is this i don't
know man not everybody there voted for
it what does malice say there's no law
too absurd or evil that they won't
enforce there's no that would i'll try
and paraphrase there's no law so extreme
and egregious that the police would not
enforce it up and including executing
children absolutely history tells that
story and now we're seeing it slowly
being put into place with oh he didn't
have this paper he didn't get the
permission from the government to be
here take them away and they and they do
blindly so they have they have you know
a choice saying hey we're going to
respond to this call hey we're going to
take this seriously and for them to
punish people because they want to eat
food i mean what kind of levels of
insanity are we in that's crazy and it's
only going to get crazier from us let's
play get worse
how much you want to bet i can make a
whole bunch of people
say the following sentence
yeah but it can't happen here how much
you want about it can make them say that
uh pretty easily very very easily right
breakfast if i said
the police will absolutely kick your
door in and drag you from your home with
no crime committed and no due process if
ordered to by the mayor of new york
nope
if i said
police
regardless of where they are would go
into your house and they would drag you
out without due process people would say
yeah but it can't happen here and i'm
not saying everybody would a lot of
people are probably going like yup
absolutely and they will because i'll
tell you this especially if you're from
chicago i'm pretty sure everyone in
chicago just went yep
because i'll tell you i'll tell you what
happened to chicago in chicago i'm
hanging out with my friends cops kicked
our door with their guns drawn and just
walk into our house that's normal
completely normal in chicago they'll
drag you off to what they call the the
black site i think ian looked this up it
was in humboldt park maybe i'm not sure
yeah they just they just take you
without due process they kick your door
and they drag you from your home and
they bring you to an unmarked location
where they effectively you know torture
and detain you happens all the time what
yeah man yeah they had they had that guy
in chicago who was electrocuting people
with a cattle prod to force them into
confessing to crimes they didn't commit
wow wow so here's what happens you look
at new york city
and you've got a lot of people saying
like you know we've had libby emma's on
the show several times and she
repeatedly defends the nypd i won't do
that uh and we the first time she was
here we had an argument about the police
because i've been like not happy with
cops for a long time and i'm like dude
27 nypd officers
walked out
you've got you've got mayor bill de
blasio who committed what i would only
describe as several felonies
misappropriating taxpayer funding to
paint a political message in front of
trump tower and then he went to the nypd
and says
you're going to protect this for me and
they went okay
so this dude literally commits some of
the highest level corruption and the
cops with a smile on their face said i
will arrest anyone who opposes you
like dude we're already there you can
defend the cops all day and night i
ain't going to do it because they're
literally they're they're
you've got the mayor of new york city
going on tv and saying we are going to
strip life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness from the citizens to force
them to undergo a medical procedure and
the nypd with a smile on their face will
arrest you if you try to buy food
but you're trespassing sorry it's for
your safety that's happening so we're
there so i don't thought you at all tim
i think that's a very good um you know
prediction but my thing is like
how do we even come back because okay
it's either comply
or goodbye like i said earlier right and
andrew tate would say resist the slave
mind because the thing is is that like
we're being brainwashed to say you know
what okay let's follow the rules because
this okay can we say it keep me you know
my family together all that stuff my
thing is okay if we're aware of what's
happening how do we contract because you
know we're aware of what's happening
where walk we understand you know what's
really happening behind the scenes how
do you combat this
uh cops should quit if there's police
officers who are aware of what's going
on they should quit many have we've
covered those stories over and over and
over again because a lot of a lot of
cops are just like i am done with this
call it out when it happens and stop
worshiping authority one of my favorite
memes is this kind of like maga hat
trump supporter small shriveled up guy
going up to a cop who's the kind of chad
here and he's like i love you you're
great i support i back to blue and the
chad being like off to the gulag you
january sixth insurrectionist and then
that's literally what's happening here
we're seeing the politicization of the
justice system in such a bastardized way
it's crazy to see it happen right in
front of our face and the only way to
stop it not comply peacefully
don't go along with it call it out when
it happens and don't incentivize it i
mean if you live in new york city your
taxes are supporting that system you're
voting incentivizing those people to do
those things remember when those
detectives tried to imprison cal
rittenhouse for the rest of his life yep
yo back the blue baby
remember when a political message was
painted on streets across the country
and we all said just like in that quote
from 1984 about how streets will be
renamed and the police came out and
arrested anybody who tried to protest it
back the blue baby remember when cops
showed up to a woman in new jersey's uh
store because she was live streaming on
facebook things she had for sale and
they said you're not allowed to run your
business got to back the blue right
man i could go on and on and on couldn't
i yes
like that are just
terrible man because now you're
infringing on people's ability to make
money to live you know and and it's
crazy because
i mean i'm originally from connecticut
so i definitely are familiar with the
city and how new york city politics are
and here's the other thing too people
are kind of realizing waking up because
i'll tell you this florida real estate
has been exploding like i can't even get
a property right now because all the new
yorkers are moving down well
no no that that's that's not true that's
that's absolutely that can't be possible
you're lying because the new yorkers
believe that miami is sinking
don't they all believe that the the
water is going to rise 20 feet and floor
is going to get wet i think i i guess
they're so bad about wearing a mask
they're like screw this
we are being overrun by new yorkers i
can't tell you how many crazy even in
dating apps a bunch of new york girls
bro
real estate real estate rent prices have
went up 38 yeah in the city of miami
alone in the past year property values
i was looking i was looking at
properties where i used to live because
i was in the redlands and that's insane
i'm like that little tiny thing is going
for a million bucks you're crazy i went
there last year looking for property i
couldn't find anything it's worse now
new york california
new jersey a lot of people moving from
connecticut as well the northeast in
general like outside of new hampshire
they're all coming down to florida and
from california as well the people
people from la and southern california
they're either going to vegas or they're
coming to florida or they're going to
texas i got it i got a house in jersey
in the and we're like thinking of
selling it because we're not we're not
there anymore and they're just like when
we got told the general like area
property value i was like
well i lost all my money
nobody
actually went
i bought a property right uh last year
333k about property for a year later
500k it's like values are going way up
man
without giving away too much private
information
they they they told us a very low number
where it's gone up since we bought it
but we bought it before the pandemic so
at this point i'm like how is that what
it's like what they're what they're
saying that the area is worth so i don't
know if we'll be able to actually sell
anything get rid of it and go to florida
man yeah man go to florida 10 30
exchange 10 39 30.
i'll tell you i'm gonna be going down
there you got you got you know dave
rubin posted this compilation of all
these floridians being like welcome to
florida dave welcome to florida it's
like oh yeah west virginia is where it's
at man we're building a big facility
we're building like 7 500 square feet 25
foot you know walls it's going to be
massive inside we're building a new
studio building we're going to have a
whole bunch of stuff going on west
virginia freedom standing well well
i know a lot of real estate investors
actually invest in west virginia
fantastic place to invest right now bro
there was a hundred there's you can get
like a history for a hundred grand
exactly
as well when i said the first time i had
a bunch of people be like 100 grand is
not cheap and i'm like 100 acres for a
hundred grand is cheap tell that sell
that new jersey property take it over to
west virginia man you're gonna use a
bunch of money and tax-free man you get
a you go you go to like the the new york
metro or north jersey and it's like
point two of an acre is a million bucks
like like if you're lucky you'll get
like .01 of an acre it's like a
townhouse sandwich between two buildings
and it's 500 grand i've never understood
why people enjoy living i mean no
offense i have family that live in new
york city but i've never liked it i've
always thought it was dirty expensive
dangerous like why you know what i'm
saying and then you got this craziness
going on with this clown world where
they're arresting you for trying to go
to panera bread without a mask yeah and
it's like come on man and the thing is
this i obviously used to work in law
enforcement and most people i get on the
job
i honestly want to get on there to help
people yeah obviously you got your bad
apples and everything else like that but
a lot of guys come on trying to you know
do right and everything else and i'll
tell you man a lot of guys resigning
from the force because of having to
enforce stupid laws like this
it's sad man it's sad no one wants to
get on the job to rescue foreign last
podcast
right now what are you guys investing in
uh for investments
cryptocurrency crypto bam retail uh um
real estate yeah
yeah are you the government i ain't
telling you
you're the face
myself the business bam exactly exactly
business real estate crypto yeah we're
putting we're putting a lot into
building the new facility because uh
this place is great and we're still
gonna have it we're gonna use it for a
lot of production stuff we already
record like several shows this place is
lit man this is this dope man as a
production guy like i love wait till you
see your equipment we we signed off on
the new building so we're gonna have 50
acres cheese we're gonna have our own
shooting range we're gonna have dirt
jumps we're gonna have a skate park and
we're gonna be able to film tons of
stuff we're gonna have a green screen
room so basically we can film and put
someone anywhere you know what i mean
it's like we could we could make sci-fi
movies or west virginia has better gun
laws right
lack thereof yeah yeah nice yeah and you
have what you want constitutional carry
i'm sure yeah new hampshire is the best
place to be in new england i love new
hampshire
if you if you if you walk around in west
virginia carrying like a you know a
barrett m82 or whatever the worst thing
that's going to happen is
someone's going to walk up to and and
say be like are you crazy for carrying
that thing it must be so heavy cool gun
though
big fan and that's what i used to live
in texas man you know gun friendly state
you know and
yeah i i mean
i was surprised they only just passed
constitutional carry in texas though yep
for a long time you it was kind of hard
harder needs to do that you may be like
you mean like open carrier no no no so
it up until last year if you wanted a
handgun in texas you'd take a class then
get like a license or something like a
handgun permit oh yeah yeah if you want
to carry it out but if you want to have
it in your house no no no no just to buy
it constitutional carry is new in texas
you can walk and buy it and walk around
with it in your hand just don't point it
at people you know what i mean
now that constitutional carry is new in
texas you used to need permits and stuff
yup wow
yeah well i bought it you know obviously
for the job so yeah i i didn't know that
but i know obviously you could invest in
firearms and bullets dude that's
something i do but we did a we did an
interview with robert kiyosaki we talked
about that you know uh i think silver i
i invested silver as well i've got
something to get some gold um but yeah
ammunition ammo is going to be remember
you mentioned that we talked about this
i got an edge i got an n all right you
guys want to know what you need to get
yeah bottle caps why
because because in fallout oh yeah
universe everyone uses bottle bottle
caps as currency of course so that's
what you need you need bottle caps
i'm kidding it's a video game
fall out all right let's read let's read
some super chats man if you haven't
already smash the like button like the
channel go to timcast.com become a
member we're gonna have a members only
segment coming up around 11 or so p.m it
goes live on the website at timcast.com
so sign up let's read some of these
super chats i'm just gonna tell you
there's a lot of guys a lot of people in
the super chats who are who are mad at
you so you want me i'm going to read
them all right let's go let's see let's
see if you guys are uh
i'll write the first one alex corey says
fake and fraud oh nice clever awesome
hey we're here to scam that's what we're
here for scammers good night headed
i said oh so you admit it yeah we're
frauds yeah frauds man
at this point
all right america float says god bless
alex jones and everyone putting in the
good fight a fight
man they are really trying to destroy
that that guy for sure man it's just
it's just sad man
he'll he'll be able to fight it man like
they're gonna need a lot to be able to
go through his stuff man his reasonable
expectation of privacy is high in what
they're trying to get so they're gonna
have to fight to the no to get his stuff
and he'll be able to get a legal team to
fight that off and then also with the
trump thing i want to say that sorry not
to cut cut
off the super chats but uh i think he'll
beat that state case if they actually do
bring fraud charges against him i think
he'll be able to beat it with his legal
team but they're going to try and jam
him up to stop him from running you know
what i mean
you're right um let me let me just say
one thing too for a lot of people who
are super chatting they're asking about
vaguely about something that you guys
are accused of doing that i don't know
anything about and they're they're super
chatting as if i would know what it is
but i can i can't i can't ask you just
the simple one adam griffin says can you
ask why these clowns tried to take down
abba and preach with fake dmca strikes
what
you want to go into it
yeah it's it's uh so so basically uh we
have a lot of people that talk about us
on internet and some of it is slander
some of his defamation and using our
content in their videos and we're like
okay cool we've waited out for a while
for you to stop you're still doing it so
oh you know what cool now we're going to
take legal action against you because
obviously we're attacking our character
and our integrity so at that point eight
is all for a game yeah i mean yeah
simply put if someone breaks into your
store right and use it takes a broom off
you have a hardware store it takes a
broom off the shelf and starts beating
you with your own broom and won't leave
and does it for four months what are you
to do well you can't file a dmca over it
apparently not yeah so they just get it
reversed or what yeah it's it's it's a
long story but
basically simply put the challenges
when it comes to public failures and
defamation cases is really hard to win
it is yeah but
you know look i i actually tell people
we've got people who rip off our members
only content which is actually
probably not fair use
so if like if i downloaded your video
and then i started just playing clips
while commenting on it it's fair use
very difficult to win that but i've got
people who go to go to timcast.com take
those behind a paywall publish them on
you know online and then comment on them
now that's the line i don't go after
them still though like they they take
clips out of context they make stuff up
i should ignore it it's probably the
best thing to do but this is this is
where people are so that one of the
questions about copyright infringement
and fair use is are you infringing on
someone's market and so that's what i
was going to say because fair use
depends on different countries it's
different where depending where you are
but a big thing on fair use where you
know it hurts your ability to get
protected by fair uses are you hurting
that other person's ability to profit
from their own product but this is
specific it basically means
like if uh
if you're a photojournalist and you sell
photos for a living
and then you post one you post a sample
on twitter and you say to license this
photo buy it here and then people start
posting it everywhere now you've got
copyright infringement because
even though it's online even though it's
newsworthy and even though people are
commenting on it they're infringing on
your market because you directly sell
this content which means you said
license it from me if you guys do a
publicly available show and people post
and comment on it you got no case you
can't you can't dmca it so for us what
i'm saying is on our website we have a
paywall if you want to watch the video
you have to pay for it if someone then
takes that post it online and says i'm
commenting on it nope no dice that's why
you can't post movies on youtube but
just say like you you can't post a movie
while watching it and go wow that's
crazy because you're literally taking
away the the the market share from from
you know from the business yeah i mean
it it depends on where you are i will
just say this just so we could put a bow
on it is we successfully removed a bunch
of videos on on that yeah that we're not
protected by fair use that we're doing
the same thing but you know it is what
it is you know we don't have any
animosity towards these guys it's just
like hey man we don't attack anyone else
we don't make hit pieces on anyone else
anything that was put up was taken down
out of respect to those other content
creators and for people to continue
making content on us negatively for for
months on end it's it's just like at
some point so you got to defend yourself
right so all right let's see what we got
here
captain mad dog says are you going to
discuss what happened on elijah's show
you are here concerning jack murphy
giving sydney watson a heartfelt fu
yes we will um with jack jack's going to
be here so i'm sure we're going to end
up talking about it several people are
bringing this up mj says hey tim have
you seen how jack murphy snapped at
cindy watson i was absolutely disturbed
yeah yeah he should have done that that
was a big mistake i know he's apologized
for it i haven't really tracked much of
what else he's done because
we'll talk to him when he comes i'm sure
it'll come up and i can tell you this i
watched the clip because you know there
it was like the same was it the day
after we did friday night after the show
that's why we're like hey
we're getting a lot of comments about
this and that's when we saw it yeah uh
yeah i i don't know i don't know enough
about what i can say is
sydney watson cindy watson was reading
super chats she asked jack about an
article that he didn't want brought up
and then he just immediately started
stamping out saying few over and over
several times
and then people were immediately like
whoa dude and then people got mad at
elijah because he didn't step up or do
anything and totally inappropriate on
jack's part um people have said he's
apologized i haven't been following it
all that much because i'm like
yo you know look don't snap at sydney
for reading a super chat you know be
tactful and do better yeah but is this
really like
you know joe biden's talking about death
for the unvaxxed in the military is
worried about a coup and alex jones
assuming the january 6 committee so i'm
sure we'll talk about it because drama
is you know sometimes important to talk
about that's what people love
we're going to have to push up the
fighting date between me and jack here
just a little bit uh you know it sucks
man i mean i saw i saw the clip you know
i mean
it sucks i mean if you apologize great
you know what i'm saying yeah well if
you apologize hey you know people make
mistakes we're all human look we're
human man like yeah man like we take a
lot of criticism being online so it's
tough it's not easy yeah you should
always allow redemption yes yeah i'll
tell someone somebody who was chat super
chatted something about another like
prominent you know high profile
progressive
outlet that was smack talking me
and my response is i'll tell you this
the one way to piss me off to get me
pissed at you is to send me
drama that other people are saying it's
true i know some people
who are like decently high profile
youtubers and they'll message me like yo
dude did you see what this guy said
about you and i'm like if you send me
something like this ever again i'll
block you yeah like yo i'm literally
researching i'm like sitting here and
i'm pulling up
prosecute ukrainian prosecutorial
documents
in in my office trying to learn about
like what's going on with barisma and
hunter biden and i have people messaging
me like yo dude this guy on youtube said
you suck and i'm like this couldn't
matter this could matter less to me and
i'm actually pissed off now that you're
breaking my concentration right and like
i'll tell you something like tim we get
that like all day every day and it's
like to me it's like we're not gonna
respond to it it is what it is we don't
make content to like cause drama or
whatever even though everyone seems to
use our name for drama and we just we're
just focused on making good content
helping guys make money get in shape and
be more attracted to women and
self-improve keeping guys from you know
hurting themselves you know
self-deletion i don't want to say that
word on youtube but you guys know what
i'm saying it's like we get dms with
every single day we're guys saying hey
you kept me from doing such and such to
myself and it's like whatever man if
people want to make drama and use our
name in the process it is what it is at
this point i look at it as free from
promotion yeah we just had a 500k party
you know for 8500k subs on youtube like
every time we had a great time uh
celebrities showed up as well as like yo
like we're doing big things for our
community and for people so like that's
it really matters honestly yeah and we
don't have to drag other people's name
through the mud to do it you know what
i'm saying like we're not as much as
people who make insults on us it's like
we don't have to talk smack about other
people you have to wonder why people
like so after the ra rugged man stuff
happened i was getting a bunch of people
sending me these videos from youtubers
and i'm just like hey like
some of them were defending me some of
them were criticizing me i'm like why
would i care to watch any of that stuff
facts
like no i'm not trying to be mean to
people who send it to me like i can
appreciate the emails and the messages
and i'm just like
why do i need to hear someone's thoughts
on me when i'm literally talking about
my thoughts on joe biden and donald
trump and the military in china i think
there's so many i'll give you some
advice everybody if you want to have a
successful channel a successful show
don't talk about tim poole talk about
joe biden talk about donald trump talk
about nancy pelosi talk about chuck
schumer talk about mitch mcconnell talk
about people that are literally up there
in the government that are doing things
that have an impact on everybody because
being like let's have inter podcast
drama you know what i'll tell you this
you'll you'll you'll you'll get a decent
amount of subs you'll get a decent
amount of views and no one will ever
take you seriously and that'll be the
extent to which you'll you'll get
traffic you're in a box if you don't
talk about that person you're not
getting views yeah and that's kind of
where a lot of our detractors are is
like they only get views when they talk
about us i mean hell one of our
detractors i kind of was laughing at it
he was live i ain't gonna say his name
but he was live on air less than a
thousand views but when he talks about
us he has five ten thousand live viewers
so it's like it just goes to show that
there's an entire market on talking
smack about us and it is what it is it's
just going to continue being able to
tell you it's a drug right here's what
happens someone will start a youtube
channel and they'll be like hey when i
smack talk fresh and fit i get 10 000
views when i talk about you know
men's issues and stuff i only get a
thousand views i should smack talk them
more what ends up happening though is
you're getting addicted to making
content that is not valuable to people
other than haters bam if you want to be
taken seriously if you want to be
successful if you want to get a million
subs you've got to talk about things
that matter to people and i tell you
this you know what most people say when
you're like yo did you see what
so-and-so said about tim pool they go
who's tim pool who's that yeah yeah like
dude you these people might know who i
am but most people don't it's like we're
like we we we we do a decently sized
show i suppose but like
i think i think we're like ranked 215 on
that is k live viewers pretty damn good
man that's what 36k well sure sure but
like our podcast rankings
215.
really it's good like worldwide
worldwide that's not bad that's not bad
are we are we are we bench of hero are
we number one and even then why are you
talking about ben shapiro we do talk
about some people sometimes don't get me
wrong sometimes there's big news and
things matter and sometimes it's things
to address but what i'm saying is for
the most part
talk about politics talk about the
government talk about big cultural
issues alec baldwin shot a lady that's
why we talk about him and you invite
people on your show that you disagree
with yeah that's something a lot of
people don't do that this course you
know what i'm saying that discourse i
think is very important all right let's
read a bunch more super chats let's do
it let's go
well okay i'll read two
one of them says fresh and fit this is
black line congratulations on 500k subs
and helping men all over the world
number 304 in west virginia lol thank
you brother and then uh
what did someone else okay so then this
guy says just a man he says great guest
tim lol jk so you got a good one you got
a bad one i like that it's not good it's
all good man as long as they're super
chatting you bro all right here we go
all right seth boos says tim your
colorado trucker segment take is wrong i
think i work incident response to
colorado d.o.t and i worked that crash
trucker didn't use engine brakes coming
down the mountain and burned out his
brakes his fault
right so uh but there's an accident is
it a hundred and ten years and you guys
know the story
truck driver 23 year old guy was driving
brakes failed he crashed and i i knew
there was something with the store that
didn't completely understand as to why
he got convicted but he got convicted
because four people died and they sent
he was sentenced to 110 years in prison
whoa
so they're saying it's his fault because
he did he didn't use his engine breaks
coming down the mountain and i'm like
dude is being stupid 110 years in prison
because man there's a lot of people that
we could start around you can start
locking up you know what i mean so i
don't think this dude should get a
hundred and ten years agree i think he's
just ridiculous get his license
permanently revoked you can't drive
anymore dude
you know and you gotta like maybe pay
restitution or something but sending a
due to prison for that long man that's a
young dude yeah man his life is over
yeah i mean the trucking company like
really if you're gonna look at it like
they supplied him a truck that wasn't
equipped for the you know for the job so
all right celeste r says hey have any of
you read the unwind series it takes
place after a civil war fought over
pro-life pro-choice issues it also deals
with the deep state manipulative
propaganda corrupt policing and mil and
the military-industrial complex sent
first
you ever hear book to
no i actually want to read it now though
yeah yeah so i was i was i was saying
this before
there's there was an article by charles
and blown the new york times and i also
said this before he even wrote it
because i think it's a common idea a lot
of people are bringing up that abortion
may be the catalyst for a civil war
so in june 20 june of next year many
people believe the supreme court's going
to overturn roe v wade which will
instantly trigger 12 states enacting um
abortion bans they're called like
trigger laws like that and then i think
it's fair to say that you'll have
republicans if they win the house
immediately move for a federal abortion
ban across the board
and then if they have the senate joe
biden will veto it but then you'll get
donald trump running in 2024 probably
with an indictment under his belt who's
going to say the first thing i will do
is sign the federal abortion ban then
the west coast states are like we're
seceding and then you get red state you
get the by the trump administration
saying we're gonna send in the national
guard to stop the rebellion in these
states and then
i just don't ever see or abortion
becoming you know illegal in the united
states i just don't see it so i'll put
it this way feminists will fight tooth
and nail man to no they want that you
know they absolutely will not to keep
abortion around they won't
you don't think so i i know for a fact
they won't
i think there are some that maybe but
for the most part abortion is not an
issue that they're willing to fight for
they're willing to politically espouse
values for they're willing to tweet
about it but they're not gonna go sneak
into like they tweet about there was
there's someone tweeting about this she
was like you know when this when they
start banning abortions we're gonna
sneak in and start setting up you know
secret abortion clinics like no you're
not like they're look i'm sorry man it
may happen once or twice but what i mean
is there is not going to be a large
group of people who are like
putting on suits and arming themselves
to go in and perform abortion it's not
going to happen but i don't know of
course but hold on
do you think right
right-wing individuals and pro-lifers
would go in to shut down abortion
clinics if it's made illegal they would
absolutely would fight for it but i will
say this though i don't think we'll get
to that point because
we live in a world now i guess we can
agree to disagree here um we live in a
world where in my opinion i think the
female way of thinking seems to be the
correct way to think and the female way
of thinking on the you know
predominantly is hey
pro-choice i'm pro-choice you know most
most women adopt a pro-choice mantra
which is fine but i just don't ever see
abortion being illegal in the united
states because feminism is strong here
that we live in did you watch the
supreme
did you follow the supreme court uh
arguments no i did not see it i did not
see it but basically all the
conservatives justices put out arguments
and questions to the um what you call it
i can't remember the woman's name uh the
solicitor general
saying like you've got no reason for
roe v wade to stand nbc news slate a
bunch of leftists all were tweeting
that's it
june 2022 roe v wade's overturned twelve
states already have laws on the books
saying as soon as it's overturned
they'll trigger and abortion will be
instantly illegal damn so look
you had uh i still don't think clarence
thomas i mean we could agree to disagree
on it but i just don't see it happening
man people think hey it can't happen
here and then 800 people storm into the
capital right or the twelve were the
twelve states like like uh mississippi
right yeah okay that makes sense so so
take a look at uh you know clarence
thomas during the oral arguments he was
like where in the constitution is
abortion or a right and and the
solicitor general was like it's it's a a
14th amendment issue you know life
liberty liberty in the pursuit of
happiness brett kavanaugh was like
for what reason is this a matter of the
supreme court and not a matter for
congress
and he's right 100
the the issue of abortion is not a court
issue
a constitutional issue
it's a legislative issue
and it's only
because of this precedent that it exists
like it's only a ruling happened and all
of a sudden now they're like well that's
the way it is when whether or not
abortion should or shouldn't be illegal
should not be a precedent for the for
the supreme court it should be a law a a
pass through legislation it should be a
statutory law that's what i think is
going to happen it's not i think the
feds are not going to get involved and
they're just going to say states you
deal with it and let's just let the
states do it that's literally what
overturning roe v wade means yeah no and
but that's what i'm saying is that it's
i don't think it's going to get
overturned that so right now roe v wade
is saying states you have no right to
talk about this
if roe v wade is overturned they're
saying states you deal with it we won't
you see what i'm saying so you just
agree with me you didn't realize it
no they're gonna they're gonna they're
gonna say just that kavanaugh is gonna
be like it's a matter for the for the
for the legislative bodies of the states
and for congress not for us clarence
thomas has already said where in the
constitution does it say this i can read
the second amendment i understand it
ain't nothing in there about abortion no
of course firearms but but to be fair
it could be said that the conservatives
on the supreme court are spineless and
won't do anything so maybe that'll
happen maybe they'll just be like well
we're scared of overturning
long-standing precedent so yeah i just i
just don't see people like fighting with
that man like
it's such a
it's something that is such a sensitive
topic especially to like you know women
in general like you know having that
pro-choice that ability to you know be
able to make that decision i just don't
foresee it happening you know we got a
six what a six to three supreme court i
believe technically five to four because
nobody trusts roberts
yeah cause i mean we'll see we'll see
but i just personally i don't foresee it
happening there's no way trash panda
says we won't have a civil war me an
intellectual jazz george floyd wrights
january 6 vaccinates waukesha attack you
know what's just really crazy about
these people who are like stop saying
civil war
last year in several cities
far leftists took over a portion of
their cities and killed people there was
a dude in in minnesota on a rooftop with
a long gun people were being shot at in
their cars in the george floyd square
autonomous zone in the chass they they
lit up a white suv with two teenagers in
it killing one of them and nothing
happened to these people and they're
like
quite literally far left is taking over
a police station and a small portion of
their city there's not going to be a
civil war oh they did it in minneapolis
they tried doing it in portland like 12
times uh but no we're not uh you know
800 people you know okay well they did
enter the capital and there was a riot
no but we're not going i mean they are
trying to indict the former president
which would prevent him from running
again even though he has massive popular
support and the republicans all no but
we're not energy
they're they do they they are currently
subpoenaing the former uh presidential
administration and trying to imprison
them with criminal charges but no no no
no no nothing else will happen this is
where it all stops
and i think this is the part where like
i know you guys are like a boss or
police or whatever but this is the
danger of when you do that you know i'm
saying effectively that area was they
abolished the police and then what
happened anarchy guys were going crazy
people dying people you know
ridiculous
obviously you got to be in that sweet
middle ground right where like you're
still able to you know you have the
liberty to go to a panera and get food
you know without being arrested right
but at the same time you want to be able
to you know have the safety and i have
an issue of like a bunch of crazy
antivirus people in masks attacking you
you know yeah but all right
one step too far says privacy never
appears in the constitution no express
right to privacy exists but privacy of
beliefs home property and person silence
privilege and liberty clause 14 uh
clause 14 is granted through amendment
oh he's naming first third fourth fifth
and fourteenth right i understand it and
i think
because look the fourth amendment is
your right to be secure and your person
or whatever yeah that's your privacy you
know what i mean and so yeah there's
other uh other amendments it's it's
literally in there do you think people
are going to write when just lean
maxwell uh free no no no no no no she's
going to jail you think she's going to
free i think they're gonna she's going
to jail bro they're going to throw her
100
they're going to throw her she's going
to get a bunch of time like well they're
going into closing arguments right now
and the the state has absolutely failed
in their arguments failed and the people
they brought forward so it could go
either way it's in the jury's hands but
uh i think the state did it absolutely
it's the four jobs it's the fed yeah the
state
the state the feds the fed's
okay
she's going to jail man she should
but the state didn't present a good
enough case from my perspective from
what i've seen yeah it's been yeah all
right all right angela mcardle says it's
not a good strategy to do outreach to
people who hate you but it's good to be
welcoming to ex-leftists after they've
been cast out by their own absolutely
she's awesome that's right
i will say this i think they'll get her
on at least one of those charges which
are going to carry a significant time
because the feds when it comes to you
know child sex trafficking always
they operate it yeah you know what i'm
saying they're the ones doing it yeah
it's they're going to they have the risk
they have the receipts
with epstein with the federal government
aiding and abetting that operation for
over 30 years that's that's the argument
that i'm making is that they worked
hand-in-hand with the feds 30 years
thousands of children got hurt paid for
by your tax dollars every step of the
way you look government intervened and
helped them out so that's why i i'm i'm
not optimistic about this case she
should go to jail what she did is
absolutely horrible and so should a lot
of other people connected to this that
were not even called to testify they
just have absolute shape one charge
stick yeah that's the biggest thing they
just have to make one sorry go ahead
some you guys all right kevin vasquez
says what's up crew love the show been
listening for over a year now i need to
move out of ny and often hear luke talk
about how great new hampshire is what
makes me what makes it a better state
than florida um the most amount of legal
machine gun ownership anywhere else in
the united states the most amount of
free schoolers um both states are great
it depends what you like i i love both
and that's why i go to new hampshire i
go to west virginia i go to florida i
spend a lot of time all over the place
uh but but it it's really about what you
personally like yourself there's a big
community in new hampshire with the free
state project but there's also a big
bitcoin community in miami which is
amazing you know growing and expanding
which it's super and exciting the
energy's there the parties they're there
the life is there if if you have a
family and you want to settle down new
hampshire is the way to go if you're
young and you want to have some fun and
you want to build relationships and
build businesses florida is the best
place to go right now or el salvador
well said if you like the seasons as
well new hampshire is beautiful for that
and you know if i was going to raise a
family yeah i'd be i'd be in new
hampshire i think florida is just
underrated man like there's so much in
florida opportunity people come here all
the time for vacation you know the
weather the food the culture you can't
miss i love it there you guys ever got
to stiltsville i'm sorry you guys ever
go out to stiltsville where is that
stiltsville where's that come on is that
key west no it's uh uh just south of uh
just south of the city
right outside i think it's international
waters where they built buildings on
stilts because the water level's really
low but they built it to like a gamble
legally outside of like you know the
jurisdiction of the united states really
what yes i didn't even know so it was it
was it's a few small buildings they were
damaged in the 90s like during hurricane
andrew or whatever but people have
parties on them all the time
yeah so i was out with this dude on his
boat and we saw a party so we just went
up to it and they were like who the hell
are you and we were like who are you
what are you doing in these buildings
you don't own them and they were like
you can't come to this party dude we're
like whatever we left but yeah you go
out you just it just goes south of uh
of uh miami and there's it still spills
a bunch of buildings on stilts in the
water i need an invite bro
well i don't think i don't i think
they're like just abandoned buildings
now
yeah and so people just go up there and
party because you're like i don't know
never heard of it man the party island i
know but not still assassins yes all
right let's read let's go name of the
game says super chats don't need to be
red or acknowledged to be effective just
have some scratch throw it out there and
influence so i want to say that because
we can't read everyone's super chats but
i will point out a lot of people
like in the chat or who are watching
they're going to see what you super chat
yeah it pops up and it stays there for a
while
lurch 685 says successful people grind
losers cry about successful people smart
people try to work for and with
successful people and learn from them
you know make a point uh luke you watch
tucker cross in a bit right how often
does he complain about rachel maddow um
like once every two weeks just about how
often does he complain about brian
stelter
once a week at least a lot right yes
yeah how often does brian suther
complain about fox news though all the
time non-stop that's all he does you
know what i mean so it's like i think
it's okay if you're talking about
someone to point out and criticize them
regardless of who they are but i also
think it's important to like have
perspective on what's really important
you know brian stelter gets what like 80
000 viewers i think
total really low yeah like it's just
like
he'd be better off making a youtube
video of himself you know playing you
know tucker calls him the eunuch
yeah yeah
yup
but you know you know perspective people
who are at the bottom are going to
complain about people at the top all day
every day instead of focusing but but
you know what happens always comes from
below man the people who climb the crabs
who climb out of the bucket are the ones
who are focused on the sky and not each
other
because if you're if you're in that if
you're if you're trapped in that you
know in that bucket and all you're doing
is pointing at someone else and yelling
at him the dude who's looking up is the
one who's going to climb out you could
be building or destroying you choose
yeah absolutely man well they hate we
create exactly yeah bam that's what we
always say blue c says tim cdl driver
here the trucker trucker got the
sentence deserved for the lives lost and
the dozens permanently disabled from his
carelessness sorry
all right 23 year old he's very young
all right let's grab some of these super
probably get that appealed
it's me says if no engine breaks because
he was in wrong gear
interesting there's a lot of people who
are following us off you know brian
knowles says tim you said all the good
cops should quit but then all we would
have is bad cops on the streets who will
always enforce these edicts
we need the good cops to be there to not
enforce these edicts but i don't know
where they're at so how about the good
cops quit and then what'll happen is
they're going to be like hey we're short
staffed and we can't supply any officers
to you sorry
you know what'll happen they're going to
be like the police are too busy
defending the police station so they're
not going to come and help you i love
that story of the guy in new york who
had a fight broke out in his building
during the riots and he called the
police and he was like i need some help
i need the police here there's a fight
happening in my hallways and the woman
went sir the city is under attack what
would you have us do yeah
really yeah there was a woman i think
was in virginia and they like black
lives matter jumped on her car and they
were jumping up and down and she had her
kids with her and she called the police
and they were like we can't do anything
for you you're on your own yep so it's
like good stuff the second amendment is
such a great amendment that's the thing
too exactly i tell people when they're
like i oppose a death penalty and
they're like so you think these these
abusers should go free and i'm like no i
think the women and children who are
abused would be armed
yeah kids
i don't know what the age is for for a
parent to get their kid a gun but like
we've had a lot of people talk to us
about how in their 12 their dad gave him
a rifle to go hunting they learned how
to be safe the problem is when people
are reckless and don't have proper
firearms culture and safety training
that kids don't understand it they find
it they play with it that's the problem
now again i don't know exactly to what
age you know a parent wants to decide
their kid can handle a weapon i think
probably they got to be a little bit
older probably a teenager at some point
but
a gun is a tool man i mean right that's
all it is and honestly even if you hate
guns you should at least be trained so
that god forbid something ever happened
you know how to operate one you know how
to make it you know discharge one safely
you know how to you know clean it you
know
i think everybody should have guns
yeah i think so too because then it's
like if you're going to force them to
have health care force us to have guns
well there's look people are like these
these evil people who are committing
these atrocities should be put to death
and i'm like
the people who are victimized should be
armed yeah i'm not saying that'll end
all victimization it'll help
prevent a lot but we don't we don't got
to worry about you know uh the state
getting involved if some you know psycho
rapist tries to attack a woman and then
she defends herself from this this evil
well you know hey look maybe people
shouldn't be evil and try and harm other
people in that way you know what i mean
the scariest thing themselves is being
somewhere where only the police and
criminals have guns you don't want that
you know i'm saying you got to be able
to protect yourself in times of pair
well the police can't get to you or
whatever and time is of the essence and
everyone needs to understand basic gun
safety you know keep it point of safe
direction how to load a gun how to load
a magazine how to you know disarm a gun
you know to break it down clean it you
need to learn these basic things all
right here we go we'll read one more
romans says hello my mom is a really big
fan and watches your show every night my
dad got a bad motorcycle wreck and i was
hoping for you uh and your fans hoping
hoping for you and your fans to support
him on gofundme keep up the great work
help james while recovering by sarah
duran i certainly hope that uh your dad
gets better motorcycle accidents are no
joke yeah um i think it's like it's like
a c like was like one in four people on
motorcycles we'll get into an accident
it's crazy it's not a matter of if it's
a matter of when you got a motorcycle
accident right three i almost died yeah
yeah
one in barbados and two here in
florida and you know what is people are
on their phones and they're just living
life getting drunk and getting lit so
your life is in their hands literally so
i said you know what i'm done writing
yeah
yeah no more spoonie jank says you treat
jack like you say people treat baldwin
i'm not sure what that means are you
talking about jack murphy
he's not here i haven't talked to him
about any of this stuff
he's coming no he's coming yeah yeah
he's coming out he's coming on wednesday
and i'm sure the first thing that's
going to happen is
people are going to be asking about this
you know
all right here last one
harry drew says recent listener and i
love your content my dad who was in a
who was a maverick thinker lost his life
earlier this month your podcast has
helped me stay sane-ish during this time
i think embodies this podcast's way of
navigating thank you all right i really
appreciate it man i'm sorry sorry for
your loss and i i you know conditions
the best condolences
and uh all right we gotta we gotta do
one more right here let's do it tarzan
jungle kung fu says actual truck driver
here engine brakes are an assist to
shifting the truck low and stab braking
when needed as you descend an engine
brake doesn't matter if the service
brakes fail it will run away eventually
interesting all right man you know i
don't know but hey go to timcast.com
become a member we're going to get to
that members segment now and we'll get
we'll get spicy with it so again spicy
guys join in it will a lot of people
we've had a few people ask us about this
you go to timcast.com
sign up on the top right and then it'll
be on the front page of the home page or
in the members only section has a big
photo you'll see it we usually upload
that around 11 p.m because we're gonna
record it right now we put it up and
this is the website exclusive stuff but
there's also a massive library you can
go back and watch hundreds of these
videos with all of your favorite people
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends you can follow the
show at tim cast irl basically
everywhere or tim cass underscore irl or
something you can follow me on instagram
tim cast or twitter if you want you guys
want to shout out to anything your shows
or
yeah man uh follow us on youtube
freshman fit um also as well personal
instagram freshman ceo our main page
freshman fit podcast and admire you and
plug your stuff yeah mine is unplug fit
guys you know uh there's a lot of
impersonators of us recently so we got
the two verified accounts so you'll know
it's us unplug fit freshman ceo and then
check us out on youtube fresh and fit
then we also have a clip channel fresher
fit clips check us out every monday we
talk about you know making money money
mondays wednesdays womanizing wednesdays
fridays fitness fridays and then every
single night uh monday through friday we
bring on girls we have discussions about
dating relationships sex and you can
watch me you know get in debates and or
sometimes kick out we bring on celebrity
guests as well yes like rappers you know
people in the news over that too so yeah
we got you guys for everything we're
going to get tim down as well one day
yeah we need tim studios
we're going to go down to florida so
yeah we're going to we're going to be
there i think in february
there's the bitcoin conference that's
going to be going on there i'm going to
be speaking at that and um
there's a lot of possibilities in
florida i want to build grow and expand
so uh got a huge
network we got jordan jordan peterson
coming in february too really yeah wow
yeah so and mckayla so we're going to
schedule
i'm going to build a free amazon in
florida that's my goal uh so if if
you're in florida could help me would do
that if you know any real estate agents
let me know but it's time to build my
expand and grow and let's do we got a
bunch so yeah yeah we'd be happy to have
you guys so yeah i mean it's only a
matter of time the energy's in florida
it's amazing it's immaculate you know
what i want to see i want to see you and
tim in the club that would be funny as
hell
let's get lit
i did a bunch of people yeah i did a
bunch of crazy clubs in
miami it's an experience but it's it's
so weird it's like a little prison
industry we could talk about that later
but anyway
i have my own independent media
organization called we are change i
released two videos today one on luke
uncensored.com about trump's pro big
pharma statements and another one on
youtube.com forward slash we are change
and because you guys have me here uh
thank you so much for being a part of
this conversation and helping spread all
this independent media decentralizing
all of our forces and doing the best we
can to kick some major globalist behind
thanks so much for having me
thank you guys very much for tuning in
this evening i was in the corner all
evening pushing buttons it was a lot of
fun i love these guys love our
conversations you guys may follow me on
twitter at sourpatchlids we'll see you
all over at timcast.com for the members
segment thanks for hanging out bye guys
let's go
you